I I didn't even have them out. So now I wasn't around the animals
were inside. Depends on what you mean by out. That is potentially
inside still. No, they were inside but at many many times you
had to let the dogs out, the puppies out there. You were in the
enclosure with them. Literally at one point that's not letting
them out. Literally literally at one point they're in a play
pin and indoors. Okay. You're you're you're choosing to be so
difficult right now. He ran around with By out chat. They mean
out of the crate into the play pin but still indoor. No, outside
the play pin, too. Like he he grabbed your wall. still indoors
in so that's not me letting them out. Okay, sure. But regardless,
it was erratic. They were hopping on the bird cage. Like it was
a whole thing. They can't hop on the bird cage. Okay. They were
hopping against it. You're you're playing semantics so hard.
Like bro, you're you're just see like I know you're wrong because
you start doing this thing and you need to
We're so good to go. Let's go. Then I'm out. Wait, what? Why
would you be out if you're helping me with like the ranch? What
do you mean?
Are you planning to leave when you buy me your I'm so confused.
I thought you got that piece of for the ranch Range Rover.
The Amaranch dream endures forever. I'm just saying. I'm just
saying. I'm just saying. Your chat thinks I'm dunzo. Why else
would you put all the animals in the gas station?
Well, yeah, but but I'm saying your chat thinks I'm dunzo. I
think I'm cooked.
Your chat thinks we're never going to get over this fight. But
it's clear. It's clear that he's abusive. You know, always looping.
It is. It is clear. It is clear. Just to be clear. You think
you're abusive? I don't think so. Okay. What have they said?
What parts that they find abusive? I think it's some like around
the idea of like not letting things go, but like that's just
annoying. Like like we're just going to make everything rise
to the level of abuse, I guess. Look, I admit I can sometimes
be annoying. Sometimes sometimes be annoying once in a while.
That's it. He has he has on occasion been annoying, Kelly. Once
or twice. Why would you not at least admit to being mean like
he's very clearly being mean and quite nasty. Like bringing up
her fertility issues wasn't being annoying. I was being really
mean,
obviously. But like I don't feel like it's abuse. It's giving
me too much power. You think it's giving you too much credit?
They're not like that good at it. Yeah. Make me sound like I'm
a virtuoso at annoying you. Well, they're just me. They don't
say they're not saying you abuse everybody. Just me. So, just
annoying me. That you're I would say you're pretty good at that.
Is being annoying abusive, though? No. Okay. But I don't think
that's what they're trying to say. Well, what are they trying
to say? Uh, that you don't listen to me. That's also not abusive.
She's having a hard time verbalizing it. Just me or does she
look physically unwell? Sometimes she can look like that. I think
it's mostly that when you when people have seen her over the
years, they see her in like a ton of makeup and like under good
lighting and stuff. And now she's doing IRL streams. She doesn't
even really put on a lot of makeup before she does them. She
just kind of rolls with it, you know? I don't think I don't think
it's the makeup. It's the sort of mannerisms and the way that
she speaks. I don't think people are I think most people know
like how much makeup does and doesn't do. Yeah, it's more behaviorisms
arguing when I'm trying to make something not an argument and
then you like get mad and you'll bring up other things that are
on Yeah, like I can see what you're saying here where she's sort
of got the one side talking out of one side of her mouth and
like not really moving her body at all while she speaks. It's
just like she's just kind of like it's like she's like paralyzed.
She's actually a quadripolgic and she's like arguing. She can't
move any other part of her body right now. It is giving heavily.
Yes.
Institutionaliz I have actually ever threatened to institutionalize
you. You did your face. Oh, also who said that? That wasn't Faith's
follower, was it? The institutionalized comment cuz somebody
said it. And now I I actually do want to see. Very scary when
you did. So when was it? When you said when you claim I was rapturing
instead of Oh, right. This is where we got to yesterday because
yesterday we were covering this, right? And this is around where
we skipped. I went and grabbed the clip to show you that Nick
was doing it that he did it on the first night and it wasn't
when she was actually doing the rapturing thing. It was during
a fight when he was feeling insecure. He started saying maybe
we have to institutionalize you. Maybe I have to institution.
Do I need to institutionalize you? I feel like the comment was
you should be institutionalizing. No, you said do I need to admit
you to a mental hospital? And you said it like a let me let me
just uh emulate you. Do I need to admit you to a mental hospital?
When were we talking about? Was this the the most recent fight?
No, this I said when he said I was rapturing.
Oh, well, okay. Come on now. At that moment, I wasn't sure what
you were going to do next. Like, real talk. Real talk. You're
talking about the actual How about Honey, you haven't slept.
No, he's he talks about how he was worried that she was going
to hurt her animals. Was it up to my shin? That's not Okay, I
we can go forward from this. We'll go forward a little bit more
because we did we did watch most of this, but I want to go to
the next time stamp here. This is quickly becoming an untenable
relationship. What are you talking about? Now, when she's arguing
back with Nick, when she's got chat giving her like the points
she should make, now he's like, "This is quickly becoming an
untenable relationship." Because I literally I literally You
started this
I know. I know, but it's not true. Like, you're literally representing
what's not true. I'm telling you how I feel. That can only be
true because it's how I feel. Well, I feel that way. You know
what? You know what? I I I don't really want to do this. I'm
just going to drop you off at home. You can drive there. I I
don't want to do this anymore. Okay. Like, what the hell was
wrong with you? Like, you were being crazy. You got mad that
I said in the moment. What do you mean? You got mad that I said
you, you know, do you need to be admitted because you're acting
erratic around the animals? I I didn't even have them out. So,
no, I wasn't around the animals. The animals were depends on
what you mean by out. that is potentially not inside still really
angry like the way that the way he's speaking has just like changed
uh cuz she's making like good points but also she doesn't know
that this is not when she was actually um having whatever if
she was having like some kind of delusion or something. It wasn't
during that when he threatened this again. He threatened it again
after when she was
Sorry, you did skip her head in the va a bit. Is there a reason
why he's that mad right now? Like did she say something that
we missed in that? Sure. Cuz I don't know what happened. Yeah.
Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. Let's go. Oh, you don't have to go back.
You can just tell me you already watched. I don't know. No, no,
no. I don't I don't think we watched all of that stuff. I don't
know. So, we'll we'll go back. So, you don't Listen, I don't
ever mind going back, Kelly. For more context, let's do it. I
do not think you're crazy. Okay. Well, that's good. I think you
have episodes, but like Wait, Kelly, do you need to know why
he's this level of mad or do you want to go? We could go back
further, too. No, no, no, no, no. What is he just said, I don't
think you're crazy, and then a few minutes later, he's calling
her crazy. Yeah, I am. Like what the I'm getting like whiplash.
He did say he would institutionalize her when she said she felt
like Joseph as well. Oh, I didn't know that later in that night,
but he did it earlier in that night as well. Cam the jelly man.
I didn't know he said when she said I feel like Joseph. I didn't
know he said it then, too. Uh, I do think she needs help, but
there are various steps you can take before having to institutionalize
someone. And they both should just be open to speaking to a doctor
or a psychiatrist. That is a good step. You don't have to like
send someone to be institutionalized to do that. It's just go
to the doctor, get obtain the lift. Explainable. Sure. Right.
Like like I'm pretty sure I mean for for the vast majority of
the things I can think of like there's pretty good No, that wasn't
the Joseph Rapture event there. Ken the Jelly Man that he was
referencing a previous event. This is this happened off camera
days before that fight. The whatever when she said she was like
going to rapture or something. That all happened off camera days
before that fight. That wasn't where she said that explanation.
Okay. No, but like that's what I'm saying. Like the only way
to bring you down in that moment is like if someone recorded
me doing it wouldn't play well. I'm just going to say because
if if you don't see it actually working. I didn't feel it working.
Oh, that's seeing it. Okay. I don't think you were going to see
that. I can already tell exactly why he's going to be getting
angry because she knows she's winning the argument and she's
laughing. And as soon as he is like down in the argument, that's
when he starts to get angry. That's when he starts to say crazy
[__] He just like he gets really worked up at these
exact moments whenever she's like twinning in whatever argument.
If you don't see it actually working, I didn't feel it working.
I don't know about seeing it. Okay. I don't think you were in
a right state of mind, right? And it didn't it didn't help. I'm
just telling you it didn't help. It made me scared of you. Well,
then there's no one who can help you. Okay. Seriously? Yes. Now,
there are so many people and a lot of them are medical professionals.
Okay. Uh, I would say the fact that he's positioning himself
as the only person that can help her. That's really weird. Well,
and what he's saying at a base level doesn't make any sense because
with a lot of people who have like who have had like, you know,
if they have like I guess psychosis or like delusions of grandeur,
like delusional episodes, right? If they have ever been um institutionalized
before, a lot of them will be ter that is the last thing they
want in the whole world. They would rather like I'm not even
joking. A lot of people would rather than get like 5150. They'd
rather just end it, right? So, actually using that on people
is very scary. You shouldn't just throw that out like, "Oh, I'm
going to have to call the cops right now. We're going to have
to do well in this." Like, you shouldn't throw that out. That's
not going to calm basically anybody who has anything like this
uh down. It's not going to calm them down. It's going to make
them freak the out. So, if you need to do it last resort, it
should be Yes. And unfortunately, I hate to say it, you probably
shouldn't let it go like, sorry, let them know. You should probably
be like very It sucks that it might have to be done, but like
you shouldn't be telling them, "Hey, I'm doing this. Hey, I'm
doing this. Hey, I'm doing this." Right? Uh and which I for most
people when they feel concerned, okay, I actually I think there's
a there's two different types of people. There's people who use
it like a weapon like Nick or people who use it out of genuine
concern. I think people can do that out of genuine concern and
freak people out, but Nick's not doing that, right? Nick is using
it like as a weapon against her. He's like threatening it, which
is really crazy. I mean, at that time it was scary, dude. Like,
it snapped you out of it. Got you to stop acting so erratic.
It didn't. I went in the pool after that thing. So, no, I I think
I was still pretty erratic. You know, maybe next time you're
in that situation. I just won't help because it seems like you
just denigrate every thing that I do. Even though there's like
no playbook on your partner to be in that situation. Oh, I know
you don't. And you didn't plan being in that situation in the
first place, too. But you were in it. Okay. I mean, that would
be no [__] right? Like obviously if you were planning
on being in that situation that'd be a whole another ball game.
Yeah. I mean that that probably would be a little better though.
Just let me calm down if I'm ever in that situation again. Dude,
this is quickly becoming an untenable relationship. What are
you talking about? You literally I literally you started this
conversation I feel. I know. I know. But it's not true. Like
you're literally representing what's not true. I'm telling you
how I feel. that they can only be true because most confusing
thing about this is that he is taking it personally that she
has these struggles and that she doesn't feel like what he did
was like what she would like which is fine because you don't
have to be automatically an expert in dealing with certain mental
illnesses. Like he's saying there's no playbook though which
is not really true. There's plenty of documentation online that
he could spend the time to learn but obviously he won't. But
um the fact that she's like expressing, hey, there could be better
ways of dealing with it. And he's getting this upset is insane.
She's not saying anything mean to him. She's just saying, "I
would prefer to do this this way." And he's losing his mind.
Uh yeah. Yeah. Um well, I Yeah. I don't even think she's she's
saying, "Hey, I I think this is important for her to let him
know, hey, I don't think that's what snap me out." Just so you
know that that's not going to snap me out of something, right?
That's not what does it. That's That's not how That's not how
I I I don't really want to do this. I'm just going to drop you
off at home. You can drive there. I I don't want to do this anymore.
Okay. Like what the hell was wrong with you? Like you were being
crazy. You got mad that I said in the moment. What do you mean?
You got mad that I said you you know do you need to be admitted
because you're acting erratic around the animals. I I didn't
even have them out. So no, I wasn't around the animal. The animals
were inside. Depends on what you mean by out. That is potentially
inside still. No, they were inside. But at many, many times you
had to let the dogs out, the puppies out. Not in that state.
I had it. Yes, you. Yes, you did. You were in the enclosure with
them. Literally, at one point, that's not letting them out. Literally.
Literally, at one point, Ryder ran off and grabbed your wallet.
That's not me letting them out. If I'm in the enclosure with
them, they're in a play pin indoors. Okay, you're you're you're
choosing to be so difficult right now. I I literally gave you
other instances in that very same time period. Like you literally
let Ryder out. He ran around with out chat. They mean out of
the crate into the play pin but still indoors. No, outside the
play pin too. Like he he grabbed your wall. He's still indoors
in. So that's not me letting them out. Okay. Sure. But regardless,
it was erratic. They were hopping on the bird cage. Like it was
a whole thing. They can't hop on the bird cage. Okay. They were
hopping against it. You're you're you're playing semantics so
hard. Bro, you're you're just see like I know you're wrong because
you start doing this thing where you nitpick every little thing.
Obviously, it sucks. K for me now. It's like it doesn't suck,
but she like I can tell that she likes winning. Okay. She just
she's enjoying herself a lot now that she has him on the ropes
a little bit. They didn't jump on top of it. They jumped against
it. It's the same thing. It's an expression. I mean, to to be
clear though, just real quick, I'm just going to say she's being
pedantic in a way that Nick has been pedantic a thousand times
to her that we've watched on stream. Literally the exact way,
right? Like she's like making little corrections and now Nick
is sitting here and is like he's losing it over her doing like
one tenth of 1% of what he's done. Sorry. Go ahead, Kelly. I
didn't mean to cut you off there. I did. I forget what I was
going to say. Yeah, I forgot. Never mind. Okay. Sorry. I I literally
I was not trying to cut you off. I I promise. I know it's like
kind of annoying sometimes with the lag. Anyway, we continue.
Like seriously, dude. Like like you deserve everything that's
coming your way. Like like just straight up. Oh, it's prophetic
that we studied Chris Brown. Okay. Cuz Emmer's about get to get
what's coming to her. Okay. The old one two. Jesus.
It's the same thing. It's an expression. Well, okay. That's what
I was going to say. You said she likes winning. I don't think
she's winning anything but being in this situation. This is just
like there is no way here situation. Yeah. I think she's just
she's like smiling. She's like probably is like okay. It feels
good that like he could be a little bit annoyed in these arguments
too. Yeah. That's it. Like seriously, dude. Like like you deserve
everything that's coming your way. Like like just straight up.
What's coming my way? What do you mean? I don't know. I have
literally no idea. I have no
What a strange thing to say. But then you go, "Well, I have no
idea what's coming your way." You deserve everything that's coming
your way. What do you mean? Well, I don't know. I don't know
what's coming your way. I don't know. I have no idea. But you
deserve it, probably. This is just so psychotic. Like, seriously,
dude. Like, like, you deserve everything that's coming your way.
Like, like just straight up. What's coming my way? What do you
mean? I don't know. I have literally no idea. I have no idea.
That's weird. That's Why is it's weird. That is the only That
is a weird thing to say. And but I think this is what Nick does
when he's like losing arguments is he makes little implied threats
all the time. You sure you want to go down this road? You sure
you want to talk about this? You sure that? Cuz I'm going to
have to talk about other stuff if we talk about this. You sure
you want to do this? You sure you want to make this decision?
You sure you sure, Kate? You sure? You sure? He always is doing
this in fights, right? And now he's doing another little implied
threat. You deserve everything that's coming your way. Why are
you making everything sound so
You know what? I I can't believe that she thinks that this guy
might might have had something to do with uh robbing her or getting
her killed like that. It's so crazy when he says things like
that, right? You deserve everything coming your way. I wonder
why she thinks back and goes like, "Oh, that was weird. Sorry,
hold on. Might need to Yeah, it's I think that's about But bro,
you're you're just see like I know you're wrong because you start
doing this thing where you nitpick every little thing. Obviously,
they didn't jump on top of it. They jumped against it. I went
I went back way too far. Whoops. I was going to like like you
deserve everything that's coming your way. Like just straight
up. What's coming your way? I don't I have literally no idea.
I have no idea. Why are you making everything sound so weird?
Just cuz you're being weird. That's us. That's us making everything
sound so weird. Why are we doing that, guys? No, I'm saying you
literally started this conversation. I'm just reading you chat
cuz I No. Yeah. All you're doing is innocently reading chat.
Sure. Yeah, I know. I agree. I agree. What do you mean? Everything
coming my way, it sounds like a threat, bro. Take it however
you want to take it, man. Take it as a threat if you want. I
don't care. Like, I I'm telling you I I literally kept telling
you right now. I'm telling you that like when you're in that
state, there's only one person who has exactly the same incentive
as you, and that's me. I'm trying to minimize. I really need
to go to a mental hospital. It's not the same as I
guarant dummy with the big five gifted. Let's thank you very
much. Overt dummy. Thank you. Thank you. That puts us We are
seven subs away from another two hours on the stream. Okay, there's
lots of ammo content. We'll probably have ammo content for nearly
the rest of the night. We'll just do pallet cleansers in between.
Okay, guys. If you like the stream, you can go ahead and follow
us on every platform. Okay. Follow on X. Follow on Twitter. Sorry,
those are the same thing. Follow on X and Twitch. It's JSOK with
an underscore. Follow on Kick. Follow here. Okay. Join the Discord.
Discord. If you want to take your support one step further, you
can sub. You can give money. You can open up your wallet. Okay.
There's a couple different ways that you can donate to the stream.
Every dollar goes towards more time on the stream. There is Kickbot.
Okay. Exclamation point. Donate in the chat. That'll give you
the Kickbot link. Oh my god. Pumpern Nickel just gifted 10 subs.
Let's go.
You win the warning. Hello. I should do unique unique things,
but thank you very much for the 10 gifted Pumpern Nickel. That's
another two hours on the stream. Four hours. 1439. Get it up
there right now. Okay, there we go. Thank you very much, Pumpernickel.
Guys, you can donate through Kickbot. You can donate through
$2 minimum TTS. You donate through Kickbot, you can donate through
Streamlabs. You can give subs. You can sub yourself individually
if you don't have a sub. You can give primers. Sorry, you can
give your primer. You can sub on Twitch. You can give subs on
Twitch. Uh, if you're going to sub, only one place, do it on
kick because it's a 955 split. Goes directly into my bank account.
On Twitch, it's a 50-50 split. It's nowhere near as good. All
right, it's not even close. Uh, finally, last but not least,
guys, if you don't want to buy a TTS message, if you don't want
to sub, there's always the Patreon.
patreon.com/jast. Couple different tiers here. I'm not going
to go too long onto this one, but yeah, you can sign up for the
Patreon. patreon.com/jok. Sign up for the free tier if nothing
else because in the free tier that gives you another platform
that you can see me on that if we ever, you know, get clapped
off of Twitch or kick, we'll always have the Patreon, okay? But
thank you very much, guys. Thank you very much for all the support.
We got two more hours on the stream already. One chill. Two more
hours. Does Kelly have OBS open? I think so. But I don't know.
I don't even know if Kelly was saying anything there. I No, I
don't. I wasn't saying it. Okay. Anyway, there's all the shilling.
It's all done. We got another two hours on the stream. I got
three subs left over. That's $15 towards the next two hours,
the last two hours of the stream. Okay, let's get that. Let's
get this open again. Hit play. Continuing on with the content.
Thank you guys very much. Someone asked, "How would I talk to
Nick on stream?" I think you underestimate me if you think that
I could tolerate any of this for any length of time. Okay, so
ominous from Kelly. I do not know. I Well, I would just leave.
Like this type of situation is insane. Very ominous.
Okay, there we go. We got everything roll. All right, we got
everything going. No, it is not. No, when you ask the staff,
that's more embarrassing. Well, I wasn't going to do it in front
of the staff. That's why I asked. No, I didn't. That's not true
at all. They were outside and you said it loudly. That's not
true at all. It is literally true. I don't know if Amaran just
doesn't remember him doing it on stream as well. That's literally
untrue. That's literally untrue. No, because the staff heard
the only way you can shame these types of people is to just repeat
what they've said back to them and then just constantly, you
know, like hold up a mirror or two the things they're saying
to show how insane they are. There's not really anything else
you can do and a lot of the time they just won't engage. They'll
just try to say the I don't know the meanest they can and then
yeah, this is just giving me like PTSD flashbacks of like my
mom's exartner who was really horrible and he did like he did
this nasty to my mom. It's horrible and not good. Yeah, it's
uh I'm surprised at how overt this is. This is very overt right
now. Who heard it on staff? I'm curious.
I feel like Angelica just said that. No, cuz she talked to me
about it after. She said I said Yes. And you did say it. I said
to you, not to her. But you said it loudly outdoors. Listen.
Listen. I don't think you were in a right frame of mind. You
literally were telling me the entire time Angelica asked me to
go swimming. She can't swim. What's she trying to do to me? It's
like, dude, I'm pretty sure that was a different day. That was
the day of Okay, so you admitted that happened then. Yeah, that
was a different You're claiming that she told you, but that was
not at the time. Oh, it doesn't matter. It's the same episodes.
No, it's not because So you're crazy on another day. I see. No.
No. Do you see how like every time he's losing, he just starts
bringing up new things. He starts introducing new things. I hope
Amaranth is following these patterns, right? He'll start introducing
new things. Now he's just, you know, what is this? Gish galloping.
He's just going to gish gallop crazy make. Right. Oh, you're
acting erratic on this day and that day and that day. Well, he's
not even saying erratic. He's quite literally using the word
crazy after saying earlier in the conversation, I don't think
you're crazy. like this is Yeah, it is crazy making cuz you're
like you don't know what to believe from the other person because
they keep changing the they're saying and it's just like I don't
it's just soy. It's like how are you supposed to put any faith
in anything that you're saying if you just constantly go back
on it? It's tough. That was the day where you were arguing with
me. We'd be talking to uh Nick today. I have not talked to Nick,
so I have no idea what his schedule's like. We'll have to see.
I just assume at some point it'll work out where I'm kind of
free and he's kind of free and we'll talk. But we'll see. I think
he would be too much of a coward to talk to me to be honest.
I didn't bring it up today because I saw them fight last night
and I was like, "Oh, there's no way he's getting on streams to
talk about this." But maybe it was the day of the robbery and
we were talking to her and she wanted to go swimming and I said,
"Why does she want to go swimming?" It's still crazy, man. No
matter how you splice it, entirely different day, entirely different
scenario. And yet your loop is yet the same. I wasn't loopy.
You were wanting to divorce me having an argument because I wouldn't
fight you don't want to win. You were telling me. You were telling
me I didn't want to. You were telling me You were telling me.
Okay. You were telling me that she was being really weird asking
you to swim when she didn't. But that's not the same day as you
saying that you want to me to a mental hospital. So what does
that do with anything? It's the same loopiness though. It's the
same. Yes, it is. That was a few weeks later and it wasn't even
on violence. What I'm saying is it's you acting erratic. It That's
not true. I wasn't even erratic that day, Nick. So, you're saying
you were perfectly sane when you said that? Cuz that's an insane
thing to say. No, it's not insane to ask why somebody's offering
to swim with me when they don't know how to swim. I think that's
a logical like question to ask. Well, it would be like she didn't.
But sure. Yeah, I I know. It would be that she didn't ask you
to swim with her. She was just asking if you would like to to
try and downplay. That's not at all. What is your problem right
now? Calm down. Uh, no one's no one's in any kind of state. I
don't know what the you're talking about. I'm not not calm. The
person that can't swim. Okay. Do not do not do hockey game updates
in chat. Please, please don't talk about Angelica. This he Nick
was trying to bring up another day where Amaranth was like I
guess del acting erratic or whatever. And apparently there's
a day with Angela that he's referencing now. And Amaran's saying
that's a totally different day. So don't bring it up. Sitting
here driving the opposite of calm. You were getting upset. You
were tangenting. You were getting defensive. We're turning around
to drop me off at home because you're so upset. That is not what
we call calm, dude. Like literally, okay, you basically spent
15 minutes dismantling everything. I did not dismantle anything,
Nick. I was telling you how I felt when you said something. That's
how I did not dispute the feeling part. But if you're saying
that's all I'm telling you. If you're saying but but if you're
saying that you were not visibly way more restrained after that,
I don't know what to tell you. I was not cuz I literally got
in the pool and Yeah. You you calmly got in the pool. No other
animals. Uh other than letting the dogs out, but you weren't
doing anything with them. They were just kind of, you know, tiptoeing
in a little bit and then staying out of the water mostly. Correct.
So that doesn't sound like I calmed down, but it sounded like
it literally sounds like you scared. No. How the is you not pacing
around and and then you know very very very what do you call
it resolutely like very very very you were just in a state dude
like you he just listen I'm I'm not mad also but you were just
crazy you're just crazy and now you're denying that you were
crazy told me you were going to do this but no hang on you just
changed what he was saying there I was like well hold on he said
hang on he said oh how does that not look like you had calmed
down and then he for some reason starts saying you were then
being crazy, which is the opposite of what he was trying to say.
Oh, hold on. Did I just miss this? Oh, no, I didn't. Hold on.
Let me go. Let me go back so I can get this. I don't know what
to tell you. I was not cuz I literally got in the pool and Yeah,
you you you calmly got in the pool. No other animal other than
letting the dogs out, but you weren't doing anything with them.
They were just kind of, you know, tiptoeing in a little bit and
then staying out of the water mostly. Correct. So, that doesn't
sound like I calmed down then, but it sounded like Literally
sounds like you calmed down. No,
that looks like you calmed down. Looks like you've calmed down.
Pacing around and and then you know very very very what do you
call it? Resolutely like very very very you were just in a state
dude like
told me that is insane. You were going to it's going from oh
yeah you looked like you calmed down actually you're wrong and
then just immediately starts calling her crazy and insane again.
But you are in a state the baptizing I was like, "Well, hold
on. Let's slow down, you know." Well, I didn't do anything, though.
Well, yeah. How can you be in a state and calm down? What the
are you talking about? No, I chose not to do anything. Sure.
Sure. Of of your own valition, I'm sure. Yeah, cuz you weren't
even around me when I was making that decision. You were like
at the front of the property and I was in back in the pool. I
hope you find everything that you know you want in life. How
does he go to this? How does he go? I hope you have I hope you
find everything that you want in life. What? What? He is insane.
I don't know. What are we doing here talking about? Because I
don't think How can you do How can you this morning be like,
"I love you. Are we good now? I do love you." But then like suddenly
every time you get upset because I'm telling you how I feel,
you want to leave me. You keep you keep repeating you keep repeating
that it's how you feel. And I'm not disputing how you feel. I'm
disputing how you reflect these things when you're talking to
a large number of people. I'm telling you how I feel. That's
not me reflecting anything. That's me. also like um if someone
keeps saying that they want to leave but they don't. It just
makes a really insecure relationship, right? Because she doesn't
seem to do that, she says some things that I don't really stand
behind. But um for the most part, she seems committed to it,
right? Whereas on his part, he's constantly like wanting divorces,
wanting to break whatever, but never actually does anything about
it. And it just makes a really unstable whatever the this is.
Yeah. Yeah. I do like obviously his his constant threatening
of leaving has now pushed her to the point where she's I think
she would be okay with him leaving like I think I think that's
broadly she she sometimes says no I want to stay together I think
that's mostly the postnup or whatever the financial I don't think
she wants to be together with him at all and I think before this
before the last fight they had I think that was totally different
that's in my estimation what has changed is that she wanted to
stay together she actually wanted to stay together before this
but now after that big fight where he brought up all those things
actually when he says she he's going to leave like she's just
like yeah please like like off like you are um no I think she's
still I mean she just said uh you just said you were in love
with me I think she's still uh she's still in it she might not
seem it as much but she could have like he could have when he
was offering divorces she was the one refusing right I think
she's like any divorce is the postnup getting executed I don't
think she wants a divorce I think she wants him to walk way.
Well, that's not a thing that's reasonable, right? That's not
reasonable. Maybe I I sure I'm saying she doesn't she's not like
she's not feeling existential dread when he says he wants to
be gone, which is I think what happened before. A lot of people
are disagreeing with this. This is my re my read so far is that
I think she is basically sitting here like, I wish you were gone,
but I can't get rid of you because I'd lose my money. But don't
worry, you'll be gone soon. That's that's how I see it, how she's
acting most of the time. Now, I it seems like there's been a
shift. That's very wishful thinking, and I don't think people
shift that quickly. We're talking about things I do agree with
you that there's probably some amount of like abusive uh like
abused woman behavior here where she would probably like keep
him around or whatever, she could be manipulated. But I think
when she's alone and she's just talking to the stream, I can
see like where her mind goes, right? It's to this place that
I've described. So, the bigger issue is the learned helplessness
that she does that isn't just in relation to Nick, right? She's
not doing anything to help herself in any avenue when it comes
to she could be hiring staff herself. She could be going to the
doctor herself. She could be like reaching out to friends and
she could be going she could do a lot that she seems to default
to not doing, relying on him, I don't know, or relying on other
people. She doesn't really seem to take any um control over anything.
So, um, when someone's in that kind of a state, I don't really
believe that they're in a I'm going to leave mindset whatsoever.
I'm being honest with you. I didn't ask you how you felt. I was
describing a situation that has nothing to do with your feeling.
You literally came down and were more calm. Everyone saw you
you were literally describing my feeling and I'm telling you,
it did not make me feel calm. When you won't let her do those
things, whatever you want to call the word, she doesn't need
Nick to do those things. Do you really think he's gonna like
what if she went to the doctor? How is he going to interfere?
Is he going to like follow her to the doctor and stand in the
doorway? I don't I don't know what you mean. There are certain
things you can try and do yourself. If there was evidence of
him trying to interfere with any of these things, that would
be interesting. And then we could say that's definitely abusive,
right? Cuz that would be insane. like getting in the way of someone
going to the doctor or getting in the way of someone seeing their
friend or getting in the way like especially if they're being
very hostile about it. But now everyone saw you you were literally
describing my feeling and I'm telling you it all right. I cut
I I thought Kelly was done there. I thought I timed it. Uh she
said we we don't know that that's actually happened. I don't
know if that came through on the stream for you guys. We don't
know that this actually happened with regards to Nick saying
uh or Nick interfering with her hiring people or or well sorry
the hiring thing I think is in question but in terms of her going
to the doctor it didn't seem like she actually contested him
when he said like that she wouldn't go if she'd set appointments
even she just missed them. So there is some amount some amount
of like learned helplessness there for sure did not make me feel
calm when you said again whatever you want to call the word that
describes a person ceasing or at least pausing to act erratic
that's what you were doing. Okay. and whether it's pausing because
internally, you know, you were thinking about I don't want to
suggest it's all learned helplessness cuz I don't think she's
well and obviously when you're in an altered mindset and uh I
don't know what kind of medications she's taking. There is some
leniency that I don't want to imply it's all like learn helplessness
but I think it's it's part of it. Yeah, sure. Something I don't
know. I don't care. The point is you were in a high state of
agitation and action and after I talked to you were not in a
high state of agitation or action. Now you might say in beneath
the surface there's tons of turmoil. That's fine. I I I I I can
believe that. But like regardless optically and to everyone else's,
you know, literal like you know like everyone was very very relieved
that you calmed down. There's not a single person who was here
then, which is only like one person who was here now cuz Jacob's
the only one left, right? But but everyone who saw that, not
Jacob, okay, they knew what had happened, no one disputed. Like
literally Jacob told me right after like it's a good thing that
you're still willing. The [__] happened to my bot
sub thing? My sub counter is gone. Yeah, Jacob, what the to raise
your voice when the situation calls for it. Exactly what he said.
Is it what he said? Would he tell me that that's true if I asked
him? Probably. I mean, why wouldn't he? He literally told me
that. He told me I wish I could do that type of thing. Like,
you know, when I'm in a heated situation, I cannot just keep
it brief piece by piece by piece of logic. Okay, we're good.
He absolutely said that. Sorry, I moved Kenny out cuz I Well,
Kenny wasn't talking. Kenny, you weren't talking at all. I wasn't
sure if you were around. Like, again, it worked. I I don't know
why you're so insistent that I'm unhelpful in that regard. I'm
just telling you how it made me feel at all. You don't have to
take it. Like, the point is this. Okay, my point is this. My
point is this. Ultimately, you would also want, if there was
even a shadow of a doubt, you would also want yourself to not
have done anything you couldn't take back. Like, absolutely.
I would be the same way if you were in the same situation and
you, you know, said to me, "Listen, you got to calm the down."
Like, you know, like I don't want to have to institutionalize
you, but like if it was in a moment when I'm sitting there asking
to baptize animals, I would understand. I would because it's
not about it's not about it's not about your against me. It's
about literally listen, nothing has been done so far that cannot
be taken back. Like I understand that you can get frustrated
with people that might have mental health problems and they're
not like helping themselves, but getting this angry at them is
just like you're not helping. You're probably just making things
worse or in this case definitely making things worse. It's just
really frustrating to see cuz it's just like an open display
of like ignorance and just like let's keep it that way because
it's not about I don't want to have to but like if it was in
a moment when I'm sitting there asking to baptize the animals
I would understand because it's not about it's not about it's
not about your against me. It's about literally listen nothing
has been done so far that cannot be taken back and let's keep
it that way. That's all that it is. Okay. Do you still feel that
way? else what could be said. He's just not said
that's saying he's saying sorry he's talking about that situation
that specific situation and what he's been hinting at the whole
time is that he thought Amaranth was going to start drowning
her dogs. That's what he's saying the whole time, right? Like
you're going to drown your dogs. And nothing had been done up
until that point when he said, "Oh, I might need to institutionalize
you." Nothing had been done that couldn't be taken back. That's
what he's trying to suggest, right? That's I'm just telling you
guys I'm not saying I agree. I'm saying that's what he's hinting
at the whole time. Why does he think that you don't have to drown
someone to baptize them? What the uh probably just baptizing
dogs is strange in general and maybe maybe erratic. So like he
might have just likelihood that would result in drowning seems
a bit she would have to hold them under the water and those dogs
look a lot stronger than her not going to lie. Like she would
be the one ending up drowning. Yeah, evil Johnny Bravo points
out and I should say as well that uh this has not just been weaponized
against her while she was having the incident, right? While she
was having what he claims is like a delusional episode. This
has been weaponized against her while she was totally like sober
like she was thinking clearly while she was just mad at him.
It's been weaponized against her. And that's what's really the
problem, right? Is is he's used this situation and the threat
of institutionaliz institutionalizing her against her even when
she's not having some kind of episode. So his his whole defense
is well it snapped you out of the episode. So of course I said
it right. That's what that's what his whole defense is. But he's
used it literally just when people are laughing at him. He's
used it that nothing has happened so far that can't be taken
back. Are you planning to divorce me now? Cuz now I'm like scared
you want to divorce me and I'm like I'm about to cry. Uh oh.
She didn't understand. He's going to get he's going to get giga
triggered that she didn't understand what he was saying. It's
not any of that. It's just that it's crazy that like everyone
in that moment was trying to help him. Everyone was right. And
and some people are a little more misguided than others, but
everyone's trying. And I'm just telling you something that everyone
on the team unanimously agreed worked. Okay. Now, you're telling
me right now that, oh, but inside it didn't work. It's like,
dude, I can only control one variable at a time, right? Like,
like, I'm just warning you guys, if you talk about this hockey
game like in my chat tonight, you will just be gone. So, good
luck. If anybody mentions it, you will be gone. Good luck. Acting
outwardly crazy. I'm trying to get you to stop acting outwardly
crazy. If you're just I'm going to stop checking it. I'm just
watching crazy that way. It's like it's still better than you
taking decisive actions like without thinking through. Like I
I feel like it's just unequivocally better like if it made you
pensive and and you know kind of withdrawal back into your thoughts
that is way better than the alternative because the actions are
what we're afraid of, right? Like in that moment actions that
can't be taken back are he's just justifying over and over again
why he did this. It's crazy,
right? Like through it can be reasoned through. it can be worked
through. Like I said, I I don't feel any level of remorse because
I wasn't doing it in spite of I was doing it because I knew that
if you were in a sound state, you would not want even an iota,
a shadow of risk regarding the animals whatsoever. Right? Like
like for someone who's told me the last couple of, you know,
last week at least, oh, no risk, no risk, no risk. Like Right.
But my dogs swim in the pool all the time, so like it would they
really I smoke cigars around your dogs all the time, too. And
they never snatched it out of my hand. Yet, you still say there's
a risk. I I've never seen you do it, and I prefer that you don't.
Literally, I have I can describe to you three different No, no,
no. Soapbox. It did happen. The way he's describing it is an
event that happened. We didn't witness this event. This event
has never happened ever on a stream. The event they're describing
happened entirely off of stream, but I haven't seen it. I'm saying
so if I saw it, I would have asked you to not do that. But sure,
but in any future, in those circumstances, I was smoking first.
Someone let him out into the big yard. That's what happened.
Okay. Sure. Okay. Like like one was obviously Jake. One was way
more recent, but like it's never happened. My point is this.
Okay. You say you've let your dogs swim. Sure. But I bet you've
never baptized your dogs. I rest my case. Like that's that's
all we need to know. Okay. You could call it swimming, but call
it swimming day. When you start saying the word baptize with
with that kind of uh religious zeal in your eyes, it's a whole
different ballgame, man. Okay. It's the same thing. You literally
get on me for using a slightly different word. It's like, "Oh,
what is it? What does this mean? Why is this so different?" It's
like I'm literally I'm just trying to communicate with you, man.
Okay. I'm sorry. Sorry, chat. Maybe we'll do the demolishment
of the day. I don't think I'll climb now, but it's okay. It's
just It's not that serious, you know? Like it's okay to like
let other people How in the world is he the one who starts with
that? It's not that serious. Well, in chat know that someone
helped you in a moment of need. Like you don't have to like literally
wrestle everything out of my hands. I'm telling you there's not
a single person who was there who would disagree it helped except
you the person who wasn't in the right state of mind. That's
Yeah. So the whole thing uh the whole thing that's going on here
hold on from a van gone. Good. Okay. The only thing going on
here is uh is he's trying to defend why he said it in the first
place. He's totally left out and he's totally missing the idea
that he's brought it up multiple times. Right. And not while
she was in any kind of state like this. So that defense doesn't
work at all. The only person who thought it was help. Sorry.
Uh I might be missing something. What did he do? What is he claiming
was such great help that he did? Saying I we might have to institutionalize
you. Snapped her out of like her delusions around baptizing the
dogs. That's what his claim is. When I said this to you, I had
to say this to you for you to snap out of your delusion. But
he's done it when she's not deliluted, when she's not having
any kind of episode, right? He's done it multiple times. So yeah,
that's it doesn't it doesn't work. The defense doesn't make any
sense. It's only that Amaranth doesn't know that or doesn't remember
it. Can't bring it up. That's the only reason that this is like
playing out the way it is right now. Like no one could handle
you like they didn't want to either which you can't blame them
cuz what are they going to do? Like get physical with you? They
can't, right? Like that's even worse. I mean the girls talked
to me calmly and they helped me calm down. My dad helped calm
me down on the phone but I don't think anyone needed to get physical.
I'm sure. Whatever. It's what you thought was best. I'm not going
to fault you for what you thought was best. To be perfectly fair,
I wasn't even sure if your dad was in a sound state of mind.
Why? Because you called him that morning and y'all talked about
conspiracy things very very audibly. I I wasn't sure if he was
playing along with it or if he was actually just as deep.
Uh, okay. Nick sounds insane now. What the is Nick even trying
to say? Okay. Like like let's be honest here, okay? Like that
conversation topic was about nothing any normal people talk about,
which is fine. Like in the in the moment I just like that's kind
of weird, but whatever, you know? Like some people talk about
football, some people talk about conspiracy theories, I guess,
right? I'm telling you, like that conversation wasn't normal
and it made me be like I think you just are living a bubble.
You know what? You know what? You know what, wife? Okay, not
only are you insane, but actually I think your father's insane,
too. Okay, my father-in-law, I hope he's listening to the stream.
You are also insane. Conspiracy theories are literally Joe Rogan
whole podcast topics. People definitely talk about them. No,
I know. But like, okay, I don't really want to have to defend
this, but like let's just say this, okay? It is weird for you
to roll out of bed and the very first thing you do is say, "I
got to call my dad, call him, and spend 30, 45 minutes talking
about conspiracy theories." That's weird. Is it weird? I mean,
dude, I don't even know. Hold on. I does anybody is anybody else
an adult who tries to have a relationship with their parents?
I guess if you guys enjoy something like the same things, you
might really just bring that up to talk to them because hey,
you just want to talk to them. Like you just want to talk to
them about something they know about, something you know about.
And I'm I'm guessing that it's not as innocent as I'd like it
to be, right? I they're both from Texas. They're both religious,
her and her dad. It's probably like literally 5G chips being
inserted into our arms via COVID vaccines. That's probably what
they're talking about. So that's probably not great. Okay. But
like I would love if it was just fluoride in the water. They're
just talking about something weird. But but they're probably
talking about something that is fairly stupid. I will I will
give give you that. But yeah, you just take what you can with
your parents. I don't I used to not be that big a fan of golf.
I would still keep up with golf stuff just so I could talk to
my dad about it, right? This is something my dad followed. Like
that's what you do. So you have some like some vein of like shared
interest with your parents so things don't suck as bad when you
talk to them. So you don't have nothing to talk about. It's just
describing like a normal relationship. I assume that's not the
only reason why she watches so much AI religious slob, but I
do think I don't know. Honestly, I don't know that there's any
goal there. That is bizarre and baffling to me. Yes, I I think
better content to watch for [__] sake. I mean, it's
not normal in the sense that most people don't have that kind
of show relationship with their father, but I think that's not
a bad thing. Okay, first of all, you're you're obuscating cuz
I don't think it's bad. I I think talking to your dad and calling
him is great. I think it's just straight up great. But like if
you can't see why you rolling up out of bed, right? And like
already in that time period at least, it was questionable whether
you had slept all that much at all. Okay. You looked a certain
honestly obfiscating obfiscating might actually be as bad as
like you're being bad faith right now. It might be. Okay. In
terms of dog whistles, it might be right up there. Wait. But
regardless, you you instantly roll out of bed. You jump. You're
obiscating. Uh just say what happened. You don't have to say
obfiscate. Like, okay, you shouldn't be able to say you're obiscating
without explaining how they're obfiscating. That's You don't
just get to say you're obiscating. It doesn't make you sound
smart. You get on your phone and then you just start talking
about conspiracy theories first thing in the morning. That's
a bit weird. Like, that's a bit weird. Like, why is that the
very first thing you have to do that morning? No. I feel like
just talking about dinosaurs is not that crazy. Oh, no. Don't
tell me Ammo doesn't believe in dinosaurs. No,
I told you it was going to be a bad one. I told you. I already
built that in for you guys, so it wasn't going to hit his heart.
Okay, I told you it was going to be one. They're both religious.
They're both from Texas. They're both probably pretty rightwing.
It was never going to be a good conspiracy. It was never going
to be a funny conspiracy that we're like, "Haha, that isn't harmful."
It wasn't going to be that. Although I guess dinosaurs not existing
maybe not as harmful whether I mean you keep saying religious
but she also does only fans. I don't know what level of like
mental separation you need to be able to do all of these things
at once. I really hate to tell you this Kelly but actually most
people who are religious are not very sincere about it and they
break like the doctrines of their religion all of the time. Religion
is ubiquitous enough that a lot of people who don't care really
about it at all. Okay, there you go. You're making sincere religious.
So what is she? Ray is religious. Ray is religious probably would
be a better way to say it. Uh but what is the meaningful part
there? What does that have to do with conspiracy theories though?
It's that it overlaps. You're in Texas. You're a religious person.
You're probably kind of right-wing. It overlaps with a lot of
different things like right those groups overlap a lot. That
a lot of the people in those circles would be conspiracy theorists
as well. Okay. Is by the merit of it being crazy which I'm not
saying. I'm saying contextually that's crazy. Uh, okay. By the
way, no problem with religious people. Love religious people.
I think people who are sincerely religious who who like not even
sincerely. I think people can build a lot of positive things
in their life through religion. I'm just saying that like probably
the people in Texas I'm guessing Texas is a hotbed for people
who are like performatively religious. But that's just my my
thoughts on it. So I think that the majority of people that would
do good things in the name of religion would have done good things
anyway. I think the majority of people That wasn't what I said.
I think people get good things out of it for themselves. Not
that they do good things because they're religious. No. No. And
I'm not I didn't say that either. I said that the people that
do good things would largely do it regardless of whether they're
using sort of religion as a framework to do it or not. Um but
the amount of harm religion has caused is exponentially larger.
Uh I totally I think that's totally wrong. But I I don't want
to have that argument on
millions and millions of people. I know I know you're going to
keep making your points, but I'm going to not have that argument
at all. I know you're going to keep trying to argue on your side,
but I'll just not have that argument. Crazy. That's Once again,
you're conflating whether an action is by the merit of it being
crazy, which I'm not saying. I'm saying contextually that's crazy.
Okay, JTO always runs. Trevor Gino, you are two seconds away
from me actually engaging Kelly in this argument and then we
can derail on that for like 45. I'll do that. If you don't want
to get to any stuff tonight, I'm totally fine with doing that.
Actually, I don't need to argue it. I can just prove that religion
caused exponential amounts of harm by referencing history. I
don't need to argue. Uh, okay. Where's the non-religious parts
of history where where harm wasn't done? What kind of argument
is that? So you caused it. I'm telling you I'm telling you where
the non-religious societies are that didn't go to war in those
ages. What does that mean? No, you don't have I don't have to.
So it's like saying basically imaginary. It's like saying water
has made humans has done irreparable harm because people have
used water like anything they use as a basis. So let's say greed.
Greed has caused irreparable harm. I I'm trying to find an analogous
example though. Okay. We need to find something that's analogous.
Basically, you're saying it's irreparable harm, but people would
have just found reasons to go to war anyway. They use religion
because it's what they could use at the time. I'm telling you,
people want to go to war. They're not. It doesn't matter if religion
exists or not. They're still going to go to war at those times.
But there were many wars that also happened not because of religion.
And there were wars that were fought because of one side was
being more religious and we didn't like it. That's why we beat
off the Spanish cuz there I need to say stop saying beat off,
but you know what I mean. We were not keen on being forced back
into Catholicism basically is what I'm saying. There has been
all of these v variet do you think that had anything to do with
with England's like growing naval presence and the fact that
they were starting to overtake Spanish and Portuguese trading
all over the world or do you think it was just religion only?
At that point Henry VIII was not happy about not being granted
a divorce and then he got into big trouble with the Spanish.
I don't not everything is about colonialism. Yeah, I'm pretty
pretty confident that if you uh believe religion is evil, you're
just low IQ. But it's fine. I didn't say religion is evil. I
said it's done demonstrable. Okay. I was just clarifying. I was
saying it's done demonstrable harm larger than the good that
I've seen from it. Yeah. And I just don't I don't believe I believe
people can use it as a justification, but I think basically there
would be things that would cause demonstrable harm even if that
justification didn't exist. I mean, yes, I agree that some bad
things also happen that have all to do with religion, but you
can't prove that those things would have happened if there was
no religion to fight in the name of. And some of them are very
specific to religion. And like um people hate bull towards other
groups because their religions are not aligned. And like we've
done some insane things because people were insane and they would
eat into these conspiracy theories. Like they killed a bunch
of people cuz they blamed them for the plague. Like we've done
some really insane things to people for no good reason. Yeah,
that's true. I just need the non-religious societies where where
this these things didn't happen. Well, religion was kind of everywhere.
So, you're asking me to provide a non-religious example? I don't
have off the top of my head. That doesn't prove that what I'm
saying is untrue. Okay. All right. I'm sure there are more peaceful
places that I'm aware of, but I'm not a world historian. Okay.
How do you not see that? Because me and my dad just talk about
I just think like basically in my head um basically I don't see
a lot of difference between religious and non-religious people
in terms of how they get dogmatic. Human beings just get dogmatic
about anything. It doesn't matter what it is. So religion existing
happens to be the most compelling thing to be dogmatic about.
But humans will always find something to be dogmatic about and
they will go to wars over it and they will fight over it and
it will be that's just human existence. That's what it is. Just
happens to be what religion religion filled that hole for a long
time. It's not filling that hole anymore. But there will still
be wars. There will be still be like crazy happening. Oh, the
Mongols were largely irreligious. Oh, true. I forgot about that.
So, so the irreligious Mongols being the people, you know, so
basically Kelly's got the ball stars on her side for the non-religious
people. based based noting counteracts anything I've said. I
don't have to prove an innocent group of not innocent a a um
what's the an unaggressive group of people who prove that religion
a lot of people have done a lot of terrible things specifically
in the name of religion. Yes. But I'm telling you my argument
is that those things could have been done or almost certainly
would have been done regardless. Why do you think religion was
so
endemic? because it was very easy to something to bring everyone.
So there's no point like proposing a non-religious people. Do
you think Andrew Tate is a very compelling person? To me, no.
To young boys probably. Yeah. It just seems like it doesn't really
matter what it is. If you don't have something filling in your
like meaning, if you don't have meaning at all, uh people are
going to be very easy to brainwash. It just happened to be that
uh that religion was the thing that was used to brainwash people
in the past. I don't think it's inherently bad. It was just the
way it was used. You you tell people like their meaning is they
have to go to war for you, they're going to do it. But if you
told people, you know, it doesn't matter what the religion is.
If you convince people of that, there's going to be a way to
convince them of that based on what they're dogmatic about. It
could be, hey, we're all white. They're all black. That makes
them evil. We have to for the sake of the white people, we have
to do it. That's how a lot of wars got fought in the past, right?
Yeah. Just as well. I never said religion was the only vehicle
by which you can like cause harm, isn't it? It's not. But I it's
it's the primary vehicle of like it's the primary I don't know
descriptor or or like how would I say it? It's the primary way
people give themselves meaning and and well it it it is a good
way to basically like structure your life and and learn how to
be a good person. And the fact that some people perverted it
to use it to convince people to go to war doesn't necessarily
make it bad mean it's bad. Just because it was justification
doesn't mean it's bad is the argument. It was the easiest way
for social control. It meant you could control large populations
because they were sedated by the concept of religion. No. Yes.
What do you mean? No. No. That is objectively true. If you think
that that's why religion spread or why it was compelling, I think
you don't. No. I didn't say that's why it was compelling. I'm
saying that's how it was used and has been used. It's how some
people used it. It still is used. Some people a lot of people.
All right. Uh, yeah. Exactly. Marty Epste. Yes, exactly. So,
but I think we've had there we had our whole look, we actually
did the whole thing. Did the whole thing anyway. We're good now.
Whether an action is by the merit of it being crazy, which I'm
not saying. I'm saying contextually that's crazy. Uh, okay. How
do you not see that? Because me and my dad just talk about stuff
like that. Not first thing in the morning. I've never seen that
ever before. Even from you, I've never seen that. It's never
happened before. That's cuz he was active. I saw that he was
active on Facebook and it's like, "Oh, if he's awake and online
and has free time, I'm going to call him." Listen, if you want
to just keep pretending like there's no issue just so that you
can see calling my dad. Okay. Can you stop with the fake like
like do you really think I think there's an issue with you calling
your dad? Well, you just said No, no, no. I'm ask Can you just
answer what issue is there? Can you answer the question? Do you
think I think there's an issue? Because it sounds like you do
because you just asked if you think I'm sorry. I'm just noticing
I do that to people sometimes what Nick just did. So I have a
I have a hard time criticizing him on that one. No, no. I asked
you a question. No, stop. I answer my question right now. Think
there's no issue then. It's like so that implies you think there's
an issue. So I'm asking can we can we can we actually have an
earnest conversation because you love doing this thing where
you try to bog people down and and I'm asking a simple question.
The answer is it is more about situationally what Oh, hold on.
Hold on. Rub, thank you so much for the five gifted. I did not
thank you because I was yelling at Kelly Jean. Okay, but thank
you very much for the five gifted. I super appreciate it. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. It's happening the actual act of you
calling him. And I've said that three different times. Like it
it's it's calling your dad. There's nothing wrong with that.
Like that'd be weird if someone thought there was something wrong
with that. Calling him first thing in the morning when you roll
out of bed after questionably getting any sleep at all to talk
about conspiracy theories on the phone for that long of time
is weird. It's just weird. It's okay. There's nothing wrong with
it, but it is peculiar. There's no issue with it, though. Well,
so here's the thing, right? Like I was trying to outline why
I thought that there was something off. I'm just giving you my
plausible reasons why I felt that way. And that is one of them
because it's something that you've never done before, ever. Okay?
Behaviors that you have never engaged in before, you know, and
then you suddenly start engaging in them and then you start defending
them. It's like it's weird. Like like I would expect you to say,
"Yeah, it is a bit peculiar." That would put me somewhat at ease
for you to say like worried about that. What are you talking
about? Call him out of the ordinary. Sure. But I don't find it
like an issue that's like is a problem in here. Did he Did he
actually get to the point of like what the conspiracy was yet,
or is he still just like yapping around it? I can't tell. He
said dinosaurs, so we have some idea, but no one has said at
all ever that it's inherently a problem. Okay. I'm just saying
that like if you tried to create a thing for like I woke up that
day, why did I think something was off? That would absolutely
enter into it as a factor. Chad is saying leaking a gate code
is kind of crazy though. [__] me.
Oh. Uhoh.
Well, maybe muting the thing when you're the other person asked
to mute it, dude. There's no way that he How does he defend himself
on that? It looks so bad. It looks so bad. Well, maybe if you
just when I told you to mute it, maybe if you actually muted
it, that wouldn't have happened. Bro, you sound insane when you
say that would be the answer. I literally gave you every warning.
I said, "Listen, I'm talking about sensitive stuff. I need you
to mute it." Well, no, you were saying if I don't mute it when
you want, then you'll leak the gate code. Like, mute also leak
the gate code. No, I just wanted you to mute it that correct.
That's right. That's what I just said. Listen, I then you muted
the gate code. I also don't have Sorry. And then she didn't mute
and then you leaked the gate code. Leaked the gate code. haven't
even I I have zero regrets about that because literally I told
you please mute it. I'm about to talk about something and then
I did. I straight up told you. But you weren't going to talk
about the gate code. You were saying if you don't mute it that
I'm going to leave the gate code. Okay, hold on. Yes, that is
actually that's a good point for her to point out. One second.
I need to be right back. You need to use the bathroom and get
some water. I'll be right back. Two seconds. The gate code is
kind of crazy though. Well, maybe muting the thing when your
the other person asked to mute it would be the answer. I literally
gave you every warning. I said, "Listen, I'm about to talk about
sensitive stuff. I need you to mute it." Well, no. You were saying
if I don't mute it when you want, then you'll mute it. Also,
leak the gate code. No, I just wanted you to mute at that moment.
Correct. That's right. That's what I just said. Listen, I I also
don't have any I I have zero regrets about that because literally
I told you please. Wait, what do you mean quietly see? I don't
like it when I'm trying to debate someone and they do a what
aboutism and then they try to act smug and I get it. This really
annoys me. I was just saying that basically I I think people
use their primary meaning system to justify wars and I think
religion happened to be that but I don't think inherently it's
like actually bad but it's fine. Yeah. But your argument was
to deflect and ask me to point out another group of people that
hadn't done that. Therefore religion can't that's not a what
aboutism. It's saying that basically if there was an irreligious
society would they not use their primary meaning system like
it's you basically if religion has been like ubiquitous across
humanity then what are we even saying? Yeah. If you didn't if
you first say it was like dismissive of what I was trying to
say because it's like to say, "Oh, I say religions can cause
harm." And you'd be like, "Well, so do non-religious people."
And that's not engaging with anything I've just said. It like
ignores. I thought that was more in But I thought that was more
in response to the brainwashing part. I think non-religious people
can be brainwashed very easily. Yeah, that's uh Nobody would
not say that. That's again, it's just an example of not engaging.
So, everybody would say that. Yes, of course. Non-religious people
can also be brainwashed. Sure, obviously. But that's not anything
I said. Therefore, you were not engaging with anything I said.
I could have sworn you said that religion lets people be brainwashed.
And I was like, I actually don't think it's and for me to and
to say if I'm saying wars and like um I gave the plague example
of bad things that are done in the name of religion and then
you're like, "Oh, well, what about the Mongols?" That is what
aboutism. No, I'm saying that's an
militaristic society ever. No, it's an example. It's an example
of a non-religious society that caused untold bloodshed and death
all over the world. Okay. All right. But that's what aboutism
in the in this in the context of us having a debate. What about
I don't think it's what aboutism at all. It is. Okay. Categorically
is because you're deflecting
and you're not engaging to say if I make a statement and say
something is bad and you say what about expert ex the Mongols
you're what aboutisming
my counterargument is that I believe that whatever meaning system
people has will be used to justify war anyway and that people
will do the things they're going to do anyway like they're just
using this they're h happen to be using religion what your argument
is okay so then example of a nonreligious society that still
did that is not what aboutism. It is a counter example. You firstly
you didn't phrase it like that. You deflected directly back onto
me and said Kelly name a like a group of people that haven't
done like horrible harm which is like again yeah it's just like
deflection and not engaging. And secondly if you're like doing
that it's just like you're not engaging with what I'm saying.
I wasn't I wasn't arguing against you saying religion has uh
been used as a justification for harm. I wasn't arguing against
that. That is like I said just historical. I wasn't arguing against
that ever. I was saying that basically the thing you're trying
to hint at when you say that is probably not true. Sorry. What
is the thing that I'm hinting at? That like religion is evil
at like a base level. I didn't say religion is evil. That's what
you're hinting at. Religion has caused all this harm. Then why?
Okay. Why were you saying religion caused all this harm? I said
it was a vehicle. Why were you saying that? Because it has been
used as a vehicle. Because it's very good way to socially control
people. I'm asking you why you were saying why I was saying it.
Because a lot of harm has been done in the name of religion and
it's also being done not just by saying why were you pointing
that out? Because I believe that it's done more harm than good.
That is demonstrable. Sure. Why are you pointing that out? Because
religion relation to her being religious and watching saying
religion sucks. Religion. Religion sucks. So maybe not religion.
Religion is evil. But you're trying to say religion sucks, right?
We shouldn't have religion. If you keep putting words in my mouth,
then I'm going to get even more off. Don't do that. Okay. So
I don't know if you're just not listening to what I'm saying.
You have a when you say something, you should have a goal. Yes.
Because you had been yapping about how you think religion is
good actually. Yes. And I was like, well, no. So what's the opposite
of that? It's done far more harm than good. Yes. So the reason
So as a counter example to religion is good to argue religion
is bad. Yes, you started saying these things. Thank you. God
I sorry. What are you trying to imply that you've just won something
here? I don't know what you're what is your point. What is my
I'm actually I said religion has caused more demonstrable harm
than good. I not the same as me saying religion evil like a caveman.
Uhhuh. That also gives space for religion having to having done
some good things too. Right. But I don't think the harm
a good enough replacement for, you know, the good that's been
done. Okay. It's just like the amount of harm is just large.
I think what do you think the the best thing religion has done
is? Um I think on a community level it's not bad. No, I'm saying
historically, what's the best thing religion has done? Yeah,
I can. It's probably Yeah. The amount of bad [__]
that's happened is the stuff we get taught. So, I'm like struggling
to think of good things. All I can think of is all of the bad
things that have happened. I don't know. Okay. Um that's not
even close. That's not even close to what the the biggest things
are. You need to think on like a societal level. How did how
is society shaped by religion so that it was like something better,
right? I mean, I come from a country that slowly started this
over time. Yeah. Joe Bro getting there, DC killing spree getting
there. Yes. allows like a society of multiple people to form
together to create economies of scale to actually allow society
to flourish and function and exist.
Yes. Oh my god. This is like this is what it was allowing us.
Yes. Wow. Okay. Perfect. Anyway, I think attributing society
being built to religion is bizarre. Surely society existed before
religion. Anonymous just tipped $3. Nick is going to watch this
argument between you two and spend hours speculating on your
relationship.
That would be awesome.
Uh I mean, this is a debate. It's not a relationship. It's like,
who cares? Is it a debate? Is it a debate? Yes. Quite obviously.
What else would it have been? Okay. Yes. Evil Johnny Bravo. Yes.
Allows like the stickiness of humanity to to take hold. Okay.
We stick together. We We actually do stuff. Cool. All right.
Anyway. Okay. Can I 420? You don't have to be here, bro. You
can go do anything else with your life. Oh my god. But also,
I think I was going to wait until the end of this argument. I
don't know if we're going to make it to the end of this argument.
I'm going to end on Twitch pretty quick, guys, just so you know.
So, if you want to head over to kick.com/jk, that's where the
stream will continue. Let me go ahead and add the timer again
and pin after. I should probably specify this more organized
religion. I don't There's like other religions that are just
kind of woo woo and I don't know if much harm has been done in
the name of Stalin.
Can you guess why that is? Can you guess why that is? That is
a very important point. Guess why that is? Most of the time because
again, you can form into larger groups and organize in those
larger groups. Gives people something to organize around that
is I guess stateless, too, which is also helpful. But anyway,
here I'm going to hit play on this. I didn't actually walk away
and go get water and use the bathroom. I like walked back cuz
you said you were silently sething. Have we gotten more into
this argument now? Are we good? Uh, yeah. I mean, sort of. I've
kind of given up. Okay. Is ammo the only thing that's covered
tonight? I think we went over Chris Brown earlier as well and
then a little bit of like uh some uh David Pacman dropping out
of the event with Destiny which we also laughed about. But other
than that, it's been Amaranth and we haven't even gotten that
far in. We're like we're like 30 minutes into Amaranth like eight
hours of Amaranth VODs. So we have to get going. I'm going to
hit play. I'm going to be right back again, Kelly. Okay. Mhm.
Okay. All right. Oh, wait. Actually, I'm going to end it on Twitch
first. We're ending on Twitch, guys. Three hours on Twitch. We've
done it. We made it. I'm gonna hit pause on this and we're going
to go over to kick. Okay, over to kick. We'll see you guys there.
Talk to you soon. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Okay, now I need to
hit play and I need to go to the bathroom. So, I'll be right
back. Okay, I'm about to talk about something. And then I did.
I straight up told I forgot I had a point to make. Could you
imagine if he was saying mute it or I'm going to slap the [__]
out of you, right? Like if he was doing He's doing the same thing.
He's like, "Mute it or I'm going to do this abusive behavior.
Just insert another abusive behavior to understand why it's bad.
Muttor, I'm gonna leak this. Muttor, I'm gonna hit you. Muttor,
I'm gonna like start breaking your It's like, dude, no, you can't
threaten. Weird, abusive, right? Did Pacman a reputation concerns?
Road Miss Prime. Anyway, I'll be back. Okay, but you weren't
going to talk about the gate code. You were saying if you don't
mute it, then I'm going to leave the gate code. And yet, if I
was still spamming it again and again and again, you just chose
not to mute it. Listen, that all stems back to should you have
mute muted the conversation. You going to backtrack from this
one? That's not their point, though. I'm addressing a point is
I'm saying that why did you start a conversation about this but
your chat thinks I'm abusive and I said so what is it that they
talk about and then like we're talking about things that they've
said and so then I start reading some from the chat why are you
getting mad at me when we're having no one's getting mad at you
it feels like you are no like literally the thing you were so
mad Nick that you said you're going to drop me off at home and
now we're at home in the driveway you literally were so so so
let's unpack you're jumping between two talks. One is what chat
was saying. He's so unbelievably right now. He's like actually
infinitely right now. It's It's so over for this guy. It's never
been more over for this guy. Now, nothing you said, sorry. Nothing
chat said like bothers me whatsoever. Like they'll say what they
say. But when you This goes back to the thing that you tell me
all the time. When you say something that weighs on me a lot
more. If chat said, "Yeah, you didn't help her." I don't give
a whatever they think, right? But when you sit there and you
tell me, "Yeah, no. My dad helped me." It's like, "Dude, I don't
know what you think needed to happen in that moment, but I'm
going to tell you that the only thing that needed to happen was
you needed to stop moving around and being so active and just
calm the f down and and what? Huh?" Even if you're lost in your
thoughts, that's a improvement cuz you were pacing around the
room. You were in my face, you know, asking if you love me. Yeah.
That's not Are you just Are you really just gonna defend your
own No, I'm just saying like you're What the are you saying?
What are you saying? Just stop being so active in your face.
You don't need what that means. You don't need to You don't need
to try and defend yourself there. You already have a buy. You're
just being weird about it. Like like yeah, you were in my face
first asking me if I believe in God, which is fine, too. But
like it's a weird thing that like that's basically the first
thing you said to me that day. Okay. Which is I walked into your
lounge and you came up to me eyes super wide and you go, "Do
you believe in God?" Yeah. I just felt like something bad was
going to happen and I was worried. Okay, hold on. First of all,
somebody has a sub notification that's like um I don't know what
it's from, but it's like something are you a man of God? It's
like an African voice saying this. What streamer has that? I'm
trying to think of it in my head. I can't Do you know what I'm
talking about? I just that played in my head just now. It's like
uh it's like some African actor who does it. Uh is it Gorkc?
Thank you. Okay, it's Gorkc. Thank you. I said and I said yes.
And I'm kind of like waiting for you to go on and then you say
nothing and I'm just like okay. You know what's going on? Right.
It's like like most people if they start with asking that question
there's like a followup. It wasn't just literally do you believe
in God and then just that's it. That's that's that's what we're
just going to linger on. We're going to just linger on that answer.
Chat says, "Well, you were you were up when you took edibles,
so sometimes just, you know, like Oh, yeah. Absolutely. That's
what I'm saying. You don't have to be Does that That's what I'm
saying. You don't have to be defensive about it, but like to
say that I didn't help you is like, okay, look, I'm saying that
particular comment did not make me feel safer." I never said
a single comment made you feel safer. I said the the act of using
logic and and breaking through with No, you you you mentioned
yelling loudly and threatening to put me in a mental hospital.
How you would call the mental hospital is the part you keep tying
in. The only thing I'm maintaining is just using logic to dispel
piece by piece the stuff that you were saying cuz you would say
something like, "Oh my god, this is just like that." I go, "In
what way? Show me. Google it."
Like when you were doing your correlation, like this is so similar
to this thing. Well, that's not even the same day. I'm giving
an example. Well, no, we're talking about I know, but I'm giving
an example of like just giving an example of like how that it's
just easier to describe. But that that you weren't we weren't
discussing that at the time, so that logic didn't help me calm
down. I I I also Yeah, it's weird that he can't say what this
was. So, he's like his argument is one, I'm I'm like started
showing you how what you're saying was delusional. I I logically
argued you down from the delusion. I would say most people who
are having an episode, I would say the core feature of some kind
of like mental delusion, some delusional episode, some kind of
psychotic break, the core feature of those is that people are
kind of like impenetrable to logic, right? Isn't that the core
feature that like they're not operating logically? You can't
logically argue them out of the feelings they're having, right?
I don't I just the idea that oh, I started logically proving
how you were being like weird and then that brought you down.
I don't know that that actually works. Yeah, I don't know. Oh
my god. It was just easier to describe that situation than the
actual situation. Why do you keep jumping around? Like stay on
the topic. A situation. Don't bring in elements of a conversation
from another day unrelated to You think you're so clever and
smart, don't you? I don't think because like because no one no
one is Oh god, she's laughing at him again. I feel like he's
going to get heated again. Conflating the two. It's just easier
for me to give an example that has the variables defined versus
an open-ended one like the one because it's like look, how do
you convince someone that they're not rapture? It's like it's
such a crazy question. It's like well I didn't think what do
you just say honey day? You're going to change day. You didn't
think you're think I was rapt Obviously I know I'm not being
beamed up into the sky. I I was told you I was paranoid something
bad was going to happen. Something like a rapture but I wasn't
sure. It was a confusing thing. Okay, dude. That's a lot of words.
I was just trying to approximate the point. That's great that
you didn't have an exact word for it, but it was kind of raptury.
So, the unfortunate thing for me now is I totally believe that
Amaranth has like some kind of some kind of mental thing where
she does have like episodes where she's kind of loopy or
illogical or whatever cuz I've seen an example of this where
she like sort of walked through a room like a ghost. I can't
remember exactly what it was. It was something from her stream.
I want to say it was after the Dobby is free thing. She does
have something and like that's whatever. But Nick, Nick, I've
now seen him try to like crazym make her when she's not having
one of those episodes, right? I've seen him try to crazym her
when she's not having one. So now I don't know that she was having
one at this time either where he's like, I logically talked you
down from this. And she says, no, I just felt this way. I've
seen both. I've seen Well, I've seen kind of both cases, but
I don't trust him at all. And yeah, Pumpern Nickel, like you
said, this how mentally ill people get abused. You can't just
write everything off as illness all the time. You do have to
try to understand these people a little bit. I I I don't have
time. She stated that she doesn't sleep well and that can really
exacerbate things, which is another reason to go to the doctor
cuz if that was fixed, I don't know. I should be in a lot better
position to just describe everything exactly how you want it
to be described. But let's just pretend like that. You don't
have to because I'm telling you. No, but but I I literally So
So look, the way the lang human language works is that like I
have to say something like, "Well, you know, you were rapturing,
right? It's just quicker. It's quicker to say that." But people
don't know what you mean when you say that. It sounds like you're
being beamed up into the air. Why don't you tell Jtock your coverage
may prevent her from getting Mama Jam just went out into the
woods, guys. She just went out into the swamps in Florida. Okay.
She was just hanging out. She decided she wanted to go try camping
in the Everglades. That's what she was doing. Tell everyone what
you think rapturing means because I just I just did. Which is
what? That I felt like something bad was going to happen like
a rapture, but I wasn't sure. It was a very confusing feeling.
Sure. Regardless, that's how you were feeling. A bit paranoid,
I would say. Yes. Exactly. And And so you have to realize that
you were going off on tangents on every person, right? like like
it got to the point where no one no one felt not safe, what's
the right word? No one felt it was appropriate for them to in
any way like even physically guide you some because they just
had no idea what you were going to think in that state of mind.
Now, you're right. The girls did talk to you, but even then,
I don't know if you noticed that they like they didn't try to
get right up next to you and and and like they were just talking
to you to maintain a conversation. Yeah. Yeah. They were trying
to just calm me down. I feel like I wasn't alone. Literally,
I was the only person who was like, "Okay, like if she goes or
starts to do something and I have to physically restrain her,
I guess I'll have to do that." That's not an easy thing to to
I wasn't doing anything like physically erratic. It's not like
I'm flailing around. I'm just walking back and forth. I don't
That wouldn't be a good argument against whatever he's suggesting,
right? It's fine. I don't understand. It's fine. Are Are you
like I'm asking a question. I just want to know your thought
process. I'm just so confused how you could not understand that
like if I have any indication that my partner is like currently
you know uh for whatever reason right having a episode and is
not themselves I would obviously want to help and and you know
kind of be standing by and and as prepared as possible like that's
just straight up what I would think would be the best thing and
if that means that barring any I I don't know how he gets from
there to like uh it's again the whole argument is sort of the
whole argument is defeated by the fact that he's used this outside
of whatever episode he's trying to describe. Right? Even if that
episode did happen, he's used it outside of that. So none of
these arguments where he's like, "Oh, I have to be logical with
you to break you out solution. They have to physically respond.
We're almost done with this one, guys. We're almost going to
the kitchen." Like that's how I feel about it right now. Obviously,
like no one wanted that situation at all. But like regardless,
I was the only one who was standing by and basically ready to
act because everyone else for for rightful reasons are kind of
weirded out and don't know if it's in your best interest or their
own, you know, like like I don't know what else there is to say
to that. Like like you know, we pay these people a salary, right?
That's the extent essentially of our bond. We pay them money
and they live. What do you mean the extent of our bond? The employees.
They live. I'm tuning in. You're tuning out. You're tuning in.
You're tuning in. I'm not. You're just confusing. Can you reword
that? I need you to admit that you're tuning in tuning out because
that was a Sorry. I don't want to I don't want to leave my chat
over there. You can kind of read through the screen or whatever.
I don't I want to leave my chat over there. I like it on this
side because it just it works better in my opinion. Um and then
I then I have the whole left side. I'm used to the whole left
side being open. You just you're literally just picking part.
I challenge you to say what I said. Right. Extent of our bond.
Our bond. Who's us and the employees? Us and the employees. We
pay them and they live. What do you mean we pay them and they
live? We pay them and they live their lives. Okay. Well, you
didn't say that part. Well, okay. I understand now. Thank you
for clarifying. I mean, okay. But regardless, I understand why
they wouldn't want to necessarily go above and beyond. The only
person who's basically going to do that is going to be family
or or some kind of, you know, um, like significant other person,
right? Like that's it. Because it's at personal risk and you
Right. That's why I call my dad. But yeah, sure. I get that.
You're right. Maybe. I'm not trying to discredit anything you
do for me. I love you. I know. But I'm just telling you that.
Sure. That's okay. I'm just telling you that like in that situation,
you don't understand. Okay. I wasn't sure if he your dad was
in sound of mind cuz let's put the context together. This is
what I was getting at. You wake up, the very first thing you
do is you call him about a conspiracy theory. Now, to me, that
isn't great in terms of me knowing where he mentally is at. Okay?
You want to hear the funniest thing? I'll just tell him, this
is the first time chat hearing this. I did talk to your dad afterwards.
I talked to him oneon one, right? And what did he say? What he
said was like I told him I told him straight up that because
I I like being truthful. And so, I told him, you know, to be
honest, I'm glad you know, we're both on the same wavelength
here because I was afraid that you wasn't and you my dad or Yes,
correct. Me and him on the same wavelength because we're talking
about like your situation, what's the best fix, right? And essentially
just give it time fix it. we're good. Not to intervene in any
kind of way like either medically or or obviously like uh institutionally
or whatever. No, just just letting it ride out and watching closely,
right? Which I agree. Like I think that was the best thing to
do at the time. How can anyone loop this much? Well, I turned
the speed up because I think they loop for like another 15 minutes,
but I do want to watch it just to see the things that he says.
I I assume his mental endurance is like actually second to none.
Okay, he can do this forever, right? Um, but what he told me
was the only reason he didn't call me after y'all's call is because
he wasn't sure if I was also looping alongside you. And if you
I don't know if you remember this, but that's the part I was
trying to get to earlier on the phone call. There was a very
distinct moment and this is not the only time I was mentioned
on the phone, but like I heard it that like he was clearly asking
you something about is Nick on the same page as you? And then
you kind of waffled a bit. You said well like you know we talk
about these things is exactly what you said. Okay. Your number
one fan just tipped $10. Here is 10 bucks. I really appreciate
the content. Billy script. You think that's what you meant by
he meant by that when he asked if we're on the same page? If
me and Nick were on the same page. Well, he told me that afterwards,
right? Well, he asked. So, what do you think he meant by that?
I'm confused. I I think he meant to parse whether you and I were
both crazy together. Cuz if if if it was just one of us, I'm
sorry for the reason we're crazy, but like like if it was just
one of us having an episode, I think he would call me and talk
about it. But it ended up being I called him because he couldn't
be sure whether I was having one or not. The worst thing you
can do in that situation as someone trying to help is open up
two fronts. Cuz when he when I talk what like as someone trying
to help to Okay. I I think you'd have to talk to both of them
if you and I you definitely did take it that way. But but I do
not think that's what he was asking because later on he said
he was trying to figure out during y'all's call whether he could
figure out whether I was sharing the trip with you or you're
flying solo essentially. That's what I'm saying. Like like behind
the scenes people care and they're communicating, right? Like
the only time I talk to your dad is when there's some kind of
crisis. Why Why would he think that though? If you're calling
him about my trip, why would you be trip? Why would you think
that he thinks you're tripping too? It doesn't make sense if
you're if Can you Can you You're trying You're working at this
from the angle. So I'm trying to I ask you to at least just keep
a neutral stance because you're So here's the thing, right? It
makes perfect sense. It goes like this. I ended up calling your
dad because I just wanted to know is it just you? Is it Are you
getting
right just $10 lady? Admit you was acting crazy. We all saw it.
No need to downplay it. Like nobody saw it though. That's the
thing. Nick's talking about something that happened off stream.
This part y'all didn't see it. No. No. Yeah. This part y'all
didn't see. Um basically I called him down and then he was I
mean you could tell he was very very guarded at first because
he didn't know if I was you know uh it's not that's very possible,
Miss Elliot. Yes, I do think it's like it's bad. Okay, she should
go appeal to authority. Actually, you can't just say my dad agreed
with you. That's an appeal. My dad doesn't necessarily know what's
going on. But yeah, like uh we all agree you were kind of going
crazy. We all agree you're going crazy, Amra. We all agree. No,
thinking straight. So, he's like, "How do you feel?" And I was
like, "I feel good. I don't think um I think whatever the loopiness
Caitlyn's experiencing is is just, you know, unique to her. I
don't currently have it, you know, is what I told him." And he
said, "Okay, that's said, you know, I tried to figure out this
morning, you know, if y'all were both, you know, kind of feeling
it or if it was just her is what he said. And so that's when
I took it to mean that the earlier thing he was asking was actually
just him trying to figure out whether we're both luby or not.
Okay. But yeah, like I mean it's not that crazy. Um, and we talked
for a little bit, but basically his thing is this, right? Kind
of like what you said. He says that sometimes you and him do
talk about like, you know, stuff that's on the fridge, right?
And that y'all just find it interesting. And then he told me
some interesting stuff which is kind of alluding to other things,
but like like what? Well, he was he made it sound like he could
relate to the loopiness that you were experiencing because he
said, "Listen, I've been there." And what helped me out was weaning
off of any medication whatsoever for the next week. However,
then this is where he got really granular with the advice. He
said, "But you have to be very, very acutely aware of withdrawal
symptoms." And so, if she starts getting into those, you got
to convince her to take a little bit um because you don't want
to risk, you know, it's like it's like a balance, right? Like
it's between um not being unstable. It's a very elaborate conversation
to have with her dad due to medication and then not being unstable.
Possible, not impossible. You didn't experience any of those
symptoms of withdrawal. And so I never had to, you know, tell
you to take it, you know, in that entire period. So, like it
worked out okay, but like he just made it sound like he Miss
Elliot, I don't know if that's true that if you took Amaranth
out of this I mean like you I would say based on like some of
the stuff I saw I do feel like man I don't have a good re a good
read but I would say you'd have to take her out of this environment
to know whether or not she had something to to like be able to
diagnose her. Like there's just too many conflating uh confounding
factors when she's in this environment. kind of knew the road
map either personally or he had been close to someone who had
and so it just sounded like advice I could actually take versus
the usual stuff he gives which is fine but it's like pray about
it. Yeah. Which I I couldn't have used very much pray about it
in that moment honestly cuz I don't know like I don't want to
sorry I agree with you guys that getting out of this environment
would be better for her 100%. I'm just saying that like I think
there probably is something going on but you it would be just
too difficult to tell. I don't think you can really like di not
that I can diagnose her in the first place, but I don't think
anybody's diagnosing her based off of like how she's acted on
stream and it's just there's a lot of weird going on in the background
too. I do think that like based on some people's stories from
like years and years and years ago, there was always a little
like something off, but I again
rumors. Yes. Who's this? Yes. Who you with? Okay. I don't have
any credit card debt. It Yeah. Okay, cool. Great. Thanks. Anyways,
I'm just telling you, man, like when you're in that state, everyone
just wants you to be better. And it's not you don't have to be
like invulnerable all the time where you just like I don't know
why it was so significant for you to tell people that I didn't
help. It's so weird. I'm not I'm saying I'm not telling people
that you didn't help. I'm saying a specific comment where you
threatened to institutionalize me does not help feel calmer.
That particular comment does not Yes, that's all I said. I'm
not saying you don't help in general either in that situation
after that point or any other point. I'm saying that particular
comment did not help me feel better. I just hope that you never
have to convince someone close to you like what is fact and what
is fiction like cuz that is just I hope not to just say okay
I understand that one thing didn't help or [__] sakes
right like but like no like obviously I shouldn't have said that
to you but at the same time like dude this is like it's actually
gone beyond him like trying to win an argument or anything now
it's just like it's just like Chinese uh water drip torture right
like if he just keeps talking for long enough she will like actually
She will actually have an episode and it will be over for her.
Like she she will go crazy if he could just keep talking for
long enough. He's like worming his way verbally into her brain
and eventually she will just go crazy. I know I'm about to go
crazy. So we're all we're all here for it. I wasn't sure how
crazy you were intending to get with the type of language you're
willing is all that it is. Like I've never been in a situation
where you've actually been like holy like he's not cogent. Except
for maybe the high thing, but I was pretty honest. True. Right.
Yeah. Like it's tough. Like it wasn't about like putting you
in to spite you. It would just be like if I cannot physically
restrain you and I can't just stay up and watch you 24/7, right?
Assuming it was that bad because there were some moments, man,
like when I would walk you to bed and then 20 minutes later you'd
be walking around the house. Like there's a lot of those. And
it was just like, wow. Okay. Um, what choice do I have? Do I
just sit there, stay awake, watch you? You know what I'm saying?
Yeah. All right. I get it. I'm sorry that I came off the wrong
way. I didn't mean to make you feel that way. It's a whole another
conversation that we've talked about in terms of your dad in
our relationship. I haven't talked to my dad in a long time like
you know on the phone or anything so I don't know what do you
mean by that just during that period in time that doesn't sound
good either ton for every little I just feel like he's older
and wiser and he's still married to this day to my mother so
if anyone is a good person to talk to I feel like that'd be it
and he also has ADD like me and has taken medication before for
it I don't think he's a bad sounding board I just doubt that
as a conflict negotiator slash in that moment that it is useful
I think it's pretty useful if they're still married like they
have negotiated all their conflicts thus No, no. What I mean
is that like asking him for advice postmortem or like about future
situations or hypothetical situations or postmortm like after
something has transpired and unpacking that with him, right?
Like isn't that normal? Like talk to your family about stuff
that's happened. That's what I'm saying. I'm saying those are
great. I just don't think it makes sense to literally in the
middle of a fight say, "Hold up. Let me call my dad and ask him
this question." That I don't think works. And that's the main
gripe I have. Right. Like when it's like in the middle of us
arguing. But that that's not something you were talk You were
talking about. You were talking about her like calling him in
the morning. You weren't even talking about her doing that during
a fight or something. Now you've brought him something new. Ah,
stop. And you called him. It's like phone. And then he gets on
the phone. It's the awkwardest thing in the world because he's
also like he's also Huh. He's pretty calm when he gets on the
phone. He is calm. But like you can tell like he feels awkward
about being put in that situation cuz who wouldn't be? I don't
think awkward understand. I get that it might make it feel awkward
for you cuz he's not your dad. I get that. No, it's not that
at all. Like I'm actually pretty comfortable with your dad. Um
it's awkward for him. Like it honestly is. Like you just have
to look at the context clues of how he signs off on these phone
calls with I love you. No, by saying that like it's not something
that he should be getting involved in. Like if you think about
the last five times you called him, he hasn't he told us that
we need to communicate more and work less. That's not him not
wanting to get involved. He's just that that was what I was going
to say. There's one exception where he actually gave what I think
is actionable advice. Every other time he just says for us to
figure it out, right? He says we have to talk it out, you know,
therapy. Yeah, but that we should know that. But you often don't
because when I'm telling you how I feel, you get defensive and
try to accuse me of like undermining you or discrediting your
help or something. That's what he means. like that's not communicating.
You can't get defensive when someone talks about their feelings.
You have to be open to hearing it. I don't feel like I was unopen
to talking about your feelings or whatever. I I don't This is
like a difficult thing. Okay. Uh in any relationship, I think
like basically if somebody says like I feel like you're harming
me doing this thing, right? that can feel like an accusation
and then it can be hard to talk about something because they're
saying how they feel but also they're it can feel like unjustified
or something to the other person like hey I'm not I'm not like
hurting you but I'm trying to think of how I could see it maybe
playing out that way but um but honestly when most of the time
when Emirates talk about how she like feels bad she has direct
like hey you're basically just like telling me I'm crazy you're
like doing these things you leaked the code right when she's
feeling bad it seems to directly correlate to some behavior of
his not like she's saying, "Oh, when you when you get concerned
about me, it makes me feel like you're calling me crazy." It's
not like something like that, right? Which can feel unreasonable.
It seems like most of it's fairly reasonable. I don't know. It's
just it's just very weird for me. Okay, that's all right. Well,
I'm glad you resolved it. She knows it's not resolved. I think
like in that situation, you just see it as I guess you snapped
out of it randomly or what? She's like I think she just wants
to get out of the car, right? I think she just wants to get out
of the car right now. Like, can we just stop? Can we stop? Can
we stop? No, I think that it took me a bit to calm down. I know
that I was pretty paranoid for a few days, but I mean like when
I went to go Amaranth is the only one who's passive aggressive
though. No, that's not true. But she is passive aggressive, but
when I first started watching, she'd lost the ability to even
be passive aggressive. She like actually was just like totally
a couple of the arguments she was just like she was just totally
like actually giving up. So now I'd say it's at least some sort
of defiance. At least she's passive aggressive. Lay down stairs.
It helped. So obviously like no one can make you quoteunquote
normal or or feel right. It's just a matter of time and getting
enough sleep. And I feel like anytime someone says help, they're
just talking about relieving like, you know, obvious symptoms,
you know, or things that need to be resolved. What you mean when
they say help? Like earlier when you're like, "Oh, you didn't
really help." It's like, "No, I just mean I was I was being specific.
Maybe you didn't hear me because road noise or whatever." But
I was saying the comment specifically did not help me calm down
the threat to institution. So that that's obvious that that comment
itself. No, but my point was that that comment was in a series
of things where basically I had to you would say this and this
are so similar and I'd be like why are they similar? Right? Like
but like I have to say it at a certain decel so that it cuts
through otherwise you just keep rambling about the next thing.
The interesting thing about your loopiness was you couldn't actually
connect two points, right? You just got them real like listen
a little bit to what he's saying. Right. I had to yell at you.
Oh, it's doing the name still the whole time. You're going to
lose your donation because you made a name with a whole bunch
of characters in it. Unlucky. Sorry, buddy. Way too many characters.
And then you just expected everyone else to see the same correlation
that you saw. And so it's very easy once you get down to the
nitty-gritty. It's like, okay, why is this like this? Uh, well,
there and then it's just like, see, there's no Yeah, I mean that
that makes sense cuz when you were on the edibles, you said you
had a problem connecting two points, too, like two lines of thought,
right? So that makes no I mean like I can see that. I can see
how that's confusing. And then once you What happened to Nero?
Nero's like best friends with Destiny. Best friends. Close friends
with Destiny. Nero was like out of here the second uh Destiny
and I weren't close anymore. Yeah. But once you bring that up,
like the other person, you know, who's tripping or whatever,
also realizes, no, you're right. I can't I can't quite close
the gap. These aren't real epiphies. These are just sure, you
know. Yeah. The mind is weird. As far as I know, Nero leaked
my DMs to Destiny. And yeah, so probably would be awkward to
hang out with him now. Wait, what? You didn't tell me this. Oh,
as far as I know, he leaked my DMs to Destiny. As far as I know.
As far as I know. Wait, how would you know that? Did you say
something to him only specifically that basically? I hope you're
I was telling them the other It seems like you've been different
since the loopy bad. I assume if they were that bad they get
released, but it's not necessarily bad. It is more religious.
You sure? So, I just hope you're Well, it's cuz I feel like that
my paranoia was validated a few weeks later with the robbery
and that actually has caused lasting drama. So, it is what it
is. I feel like I spoke to Nero a little bit after. Like it would
have been like a month or so after all of this stuff happened,
but like when my account got just I can't remember how long it
been since I've spoken to just that you control Teddy too much
low zip mouth right sparkle is this accent is horrible. Sparkle
sparkle true. Thank you Nick Wick Lee for the tip for the tip
for the five. Let's go. This situation isn't easy for anyone.
Yeah. Oh, sorry Kelly. What were you saying about it? You talked
to him after or something? Yeah, I'm just surprised he uh did
that. That's kind of weird. Um yeah, I don't know. It's been
a while cuz I I used to just join his Discord to like talk about
doctor related. I don't know. Feels like two of his friends were
like um one of them was a doctor and the other one was studying
I think as well. I don't know. We should just go and bother with
them about stuff. Are you sure? Yeah, I don't know. I don't think
they all had an issue with you. Is like TC Brady been okay with
you?
Didn't they all leave the Discord? I thought they all left the
Discord. Am I crazy? Maybe they didn't. Uh, I have no clue. I
mean, I don't know if you attempted to like speak to any of them,
but I mean, a lot of people left the Discord because Destiny
was kind of like headhunting people. So, I don't Yeah, TC Brady
and Euro both left the Discord. They are ride or dies for Destiny.
That's why TC Brady leaked all of Molina's text to Destiny, right?
Yeah, I guess so. But I I didn't get the impression that they
were like um I don't know about ride or die. I mean, I I figured
they had some ride or diesel. Yeah. You know, they're they're
ride or ties 100%. Yeah, streaming is good for us. Yeah, I think
it's funny. Why it just feels like we butt heads a lot more on
stream than off stream. I think it's because we're around each
other more. Think about when we around each other when it was
just me streaming. We probably butheads about around the same
just as much. We just weren't around each other as much, but
when we were about the same frequency. Well, so what's the issue?
I think we just gave couples therapy to address our individual
communication styles because we seem to talk past each other
sometimes. I think pretty frequently. Yeah. I would love to work
things in a way that you didn't get offended by them. I would
love to hear things I don't get offended. And I would also like
you to not get offensive, too. So, if I could work on the way
I deliver my lines, that would be great. I try to get you out
more often than not nowadays. Wow. I don't know about that. I
try to hear you out more often than not nowadays. That's true.
It's that used to be. You have gotten better in that regard.
Like me not listening to you was never an issue. It still isn't
an issue. It's just like it's like you're pointing to optical
things that are like, "Oh, yeah. This wasn't perfectly listened."
Like, sure, but like directionally, you know, I understand the
assignment. Yeah. No, I believe you. Well, now what? Um, I guess
I'll just go to pet on my own and find a thermometer cuz I climb
them all now. You go the shooting range. I guess it's not. Okay.
Thank god we're finally done. Time, but I guns in my car. They
not quite yet. My car. So, I'm just going to take my car and
good. Sure. No yoga. How many do yoga pets are? Just saying.
I didn't think uh listen last time. No joke. I'm not going to
go. All right. I'm going to shut the [__] up. Oh,
learning at last. Chad's like, "Yeah, kick the butt now." Dude,
this is like those like after the guy gets he gets kicked out
of the car.
On your way.
Okay, that was one of the the things here. This says switch to
next stream. I'm not going to switch to next stream because we
only have so much time in the day. And we're going to go to that
that argument from later in the day. The 10 hours. Yes, 10 hours
13 is around where this starts. We We'll go start around here.
Single Have they had a single day like this last week where they
didn't argue? I Yeah, they've had some days where they didn't
really argue, but there's a bit other stuff going on. We have
to get to the end of this vlog because there's some important
[__] coming. Okay. Very important developments we
have to get to. No spoilers. We have to get to these very important
important developments though. Okay. Wait, they didn't resolve
it. As long as that was, would it even be a spoiler? I mean,
what do you mean? That's what as long as that was. What? I said
if it was as long as the last bit that we just watched, would
it really be a spoiler? I feel like you could tell us what would
happen and it still wouldn't really spoil anything. Oh, no. It
is a spoiler. We're going to keep it. Like, if you're trying
to look, let's be honest here, okay? If you're trying to show
chat, right, that horses are great. Oh my god, there's this like
hidden world with horses and you know, everyone should at least
be you know world of horses and for how pretty they are get it
because it's like a human connection with horses for centuries
humankind and horses like people just kind of get it and if you
rely on that then you'll get the audience that you'll get but
like if you want a bigger audience then you're going to have
to do something different. We're not talking about audience.
We're talking about you. What I'm saying is that like you should
be reing in the opportunity which is that you can So you're not
giddy about everything then. I didn't say I was gy about anything.
I said anything about everything. I said anything that's not
you know like an unpleasant experience. How have horses been
unpleasant? You've never had a bad horse experience. no horse
has ever kicked you or you've never fallen off. You've never
bucked off with you want them. It's more so that and this isn't
this isn't typically your fault. It's just more so that like
the experiences because they're laced with other drama is not
when you go to the barn and ride the horse what dramas at least
with you told me it's always peaceful and relaxing. No, that
that part is it's usually the the getting there part that like
is a whole driving 30 minutes. No, the the literally you saying
it and then sometimes us arguing oh did work out five times blah
blah blah and they're arguing about horses horse riding on the
beach in California. Okay, so we watched a little bit of this
yesterday. Basically, they're arguing about horses. Nick's talking
about why he doesn't necessarily like horses, and she's like,
"Well, actually, we've had dates that have been really very good
with horses." I think he says basically after you go horse riding,
you get like really mad at me. Um, I'm going to skip forward
a little bit until this gets a little more heated. It's basically
he starts talking about how like the reason he doesn't like the
horses, the reason he doesn't do stuff with the horses or whatever,
or he doesn't like to go to furry Fridays to go to like hang
out with the horses, whatever. The that's mostly because like
she's after riding the horses or like it's like a point of contention,
the relationship or something. Generally around the act of even
going. I've said that already. What do you mean? That was that
was it right there. Uh Barry Q. Thank you for the 15 months,
buddy. Thank you. Thank you. We're very serious. Generally around
the act of even going. I've said that already. What do you mean?
So, we've had some very serious things happen around the act
of even going to see the horses. We literally just go to Three
Friday. We just drive there. Well, now we do. That's correct.
Yeah. Now we do. Back in the day, it was not planned like that.
It was just because me asking and you saying was a waste of time
back in the day. You were always like, "Oh, talk to content."
Because you weren't like willing to help me with it. First of
all, the onus needs to be on you to make something you want to
do good content, right? It can't be on other people. And so,
so yes, the ownus the content should be different from the personal
experience, right? So, I'm saying why are you saying you've had
a bad experience? Because the situations that usually lead to
me uh going horseback riding have already colored it as unenjoyable
situation. What do you mean? We've literally been on horseback
riding dates. How are those bad experiences? Okay, look, if you
like to point out the the the places it's not true, that's great.
I can I'm trying to find out the places. I think it's funny.
She's really defensive over the horses. She loves her horses.
Really? You keep bringing up every other scenario under the sun.
Well, I'm just trying to figure out what you mean. You're not
being You're not actually trying to figure out what I mean because
you're not even letting me finish any sentence. Like, you're
just you're just jumping in to me just cuz you're being vague.
I'm actually I'm not being vague. You just jump down my throat.
You're straight up jumping down my throat. Am I? I don't mean
to be. I don't think I am. I'm trying to answer a question. And
have you noticed like I don't get to finish my sentence. It's
just you jumping in at the end throwing in your two cents. No,
I You've been saying a thing and it's vague so I'm asking because
I'm confused. These two bicker so much. Yes, hell they do. That's
why we're watching. If they were well adjusted, we wouldn't be
watching. Yes, that is what happens. You're trying to say Oh,
no. You're straight up like I'm not done with it. My sentence.
You're just jumping in every time. I'm sorry. Finish your sentence
then. Tell me what bad appearances there are. Are you act I'm
sorry. What? Say that. Say that with a little more like believability,
right? What? I I don't know how it wasn't believable. Well, I'm
sorry. I I didn't say it like that. You said I'm sorry. I didn't
intend to finish this. I don't know why this one turned off.
Why does it start too long? Is is that how Androids go? I don't
know about Is that the same model as mine or the Yes, should
be just different color. Just hold the button down longer again.
Oh, don't don't double press it. Just hold You just double press
it. Just Yeah, sure. Yeah, it seemed like I needed to turn back
on again when I turned off. But um anyways, no, like like I said,
uh it's a situation around the horses that makes Listen, Nick
Nick is based, okay? He knows he knows the best movies. Thank
you, but I prefer it my way. That's basically him all the time.
Whenever she says something, stop saying it your way. Say it
my way. Enjoyable. I love that movie, by the way. That's my favorite
movie ever.
Top five favorite movies ever. Like the situation when we're
discussing when to go, what happens, and then also like I said,
it seems like afterwards, I'm sure you're you're actually more
happy. It just doesn't seem measurable that you are. Like I I
can't
and be like, oh yeah, um you know, she's more, you know, chipper
afterwards. Uh you know, she's more whatever. The only thing
you are more afterwards, which I get it because the physical
activity is you're more tired and irritable. Oh, that's where
she says fatigue. I'm not even trying to make a thing. I'm just
saying it starts breaking even harder if you put a lot more attention
into how you act around these things that you enjoy. I feel like
Do you mean fatigued like just like at the end of the day?
Yeah. No, no, absolutely. But the fatigue comes out in like you
not wanting to do anything or you not wanting to like really
engage with whatever it is, you know, like that I'm doing. Are
you saying like a [__] or what are you saying? Oh,
no. I'm not I'm not alluding to anything. I'm talking about just
in general very broadly. Dude, I feel like I'm taking crazy kills
here. Just think back to any day where you did a first Friday,
right? Okay. So, the past four weeks roughly. Sure. Sure. Right.
Okay. You come back and you're a little bit more irritable. I
don't think that's true. Cuz noticed that on those days I'm just
happy all day. So, he's basically like, you're a little more
irritable. And she says, I don't think that's true. And he's
going to say that that is I'm almost certain he's going to say
again that you're jumping down my throat. You let won't let me
finish a sentence. It's like, bro, you're you're accusing her
of something. She's saying I disagree. You could just continue
explaining if you have like some evidence. Stop just saying it
happened instead of actually like saying what happened. Well,
you're there. Sure. No, like I'm pretty happy the rest of the
day, too. Maybe it's just separation from me. Maybe that's what
it is. No, you're with me, though. No, not the last two times.
That's nothing to do with separation from you. But my point is
that like look, I I can just if you want me to, I can record
it like write it down when it happens. Like it's it's not rocket
science here. you you get more tired, fatigued, whatever you
want to call it, and then you become a little more irritable
about like a whole host of things. If if I'm irritable, it's
not because I went to the horse thing. It's because something
irritated me. It's nothing to do with me being at the barn. You're
just blaming it on that. You asked me for my opinion and that's
my opinion and now it's my fault that it's my like right now
I'm irritated a little bit, but I didn't go to see the horses
today. So, see, so what I mean, it's like if I become irritated
later in the night, it's not necessarily horse related. Okay.
Um, it's really his argument is if you go to see the horses,
you get really mad and that's why I don't like you seeing the
horses. Having this conversation strange literally strip said,
"Oh, I'm tired that I went to the barn at this time." No, I did
not say that today. I didn't say today. I'm saying saying that's
what it would sound like if you said today. That's what it would
sound like, right? It's basically I didn't say that yesterday
and I still gave you a blow drop. I don't understand what I didn't
say you did. Why you Why are you Why do you think Basically,
so Nick is saying Nick gets in like these arguments with her.
He's like, "You're so you're so irritable after these things."
And Amaranth thinks like, "Well, she's basically, you know, in
her head." I guess what she thinks is, "No, I wasn't irritable.
I came home and I blew you anyway." Even after furry Fridays,
when I went to the bar, I didn't say it at all. Why do you think
it's such an effective strategy to constantly tell me what you
definitely didn't say? I don't need to know what you definitely
didn't say. I'm not saying you did say. You're saying it as if
it's like you're quoting me. Well, I was just giving you an example,
but sure. What do examples do though? We're trying to address
like an actual thing. Are are you Say that question again. Okay.
Slowly. What does giving an example that isn't what happened
do for the conversation if we are trying to address something
that actually has happened in the past?
It's way easier to address hypothetical things and and be able
to unpack the logic behind it than it is to unpack things that
actually happened and therefore we have emotional stigma or attachments
to that's not what she said. She's literally you have a factual
disagreement on whether or not the thing you said happened happened.
She's saying it didn't happen. You're saying it did. She's saying
why would you give examples of things that didn't happen? because
she's trying to argue it didn't happen but instead of that you're
you're like you've tried to bo down something else. Why would
you have to address a hypothetical situation? Are you serious?
M just tip five.
Hold on.
What your problem say with a more
variable all of a sudden? You're a taboo all of a sudden. Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you for the donation. There's a wild but but
there's if if it's a hypothetical situation that means it didn't
happen. So why would you have to debate it if it didn't happen?
Because you were using it to unpack conceptually something that
did happen but without the baggage. I'm not using it. You're
using it. Sure. I'm using it then. It's fine. I'm asking you
about why you feel this way. You can't bring up a hypothetical
situation. We're asking why or I'm asking Well, I I did try to
directly I did directly try to mention it, but then you just
kept miring me in details, right? Like and so so then I gave
an example. What do you
So I I don't know. I'm having a little bit of a hard time following.
Exactly. But Nick is saying this is like this is another thing
where like he's just trying to he's basically trying to describe
how he feels and she's saying that's not what happened. Right?
So he's trying to he was trying to give examples and she's going
that's not what happened. That's what not what happened. And
so he goes to a hypothetical and she's like no no you have to
figure out what happened. Why are you mad at me? Why do you feel
this way? Stop giving me like hypothetical reasons or something.
Say what happened that actually you have rooted in reality in
any way. That's what she said. What does that mean? Why aren't
you in details? I've told you already. Like there are multiple
times when you'll say that you're tired and then but you just
said that was a hypothetical so it's not multiple times. You
said that that was a hypothetical thing. Like me saying it in
that instance because you didn't go to the barn today is a hypothetical.
Correct. Okay. But it's being used to illustrate that you do
say that unironically at other times and it's not hypothetical.
What do you what which which part? Unironically at other times.
We're we're talking about days specifically that I go to the
barn. Correct. And so I'm pretty sure all the past barn days
I've been very happy. Um, I'm glad that that's your recollection
after the fact. I guess I mean I would say giving you a [__]
shows I'm pretty happy because even though like did I ever did
I say at any point that that's not the case. Like that's the
weird part. You keep bringing up things that no one's disagreeing
to and I feel like you think. So Nick said when you go to furry
Fridays you come back you're like tired and irritable and you're
she says yesterday I came home after riding my horses and blew
you even though you're an So counter example. And then he goes
why would you bring that up? That has nothing to do with what
I'm saying. So, what he needs to do is bring up an example of
when she's come home and been like super with him or something.
That's what he needs to do. Or, hey, here's like three or four
days, three or four times in a row you were like really rude
after scoring some kind of point when you attack these. Like,
I'm not scoring a point. I'm trying to You're attacking straw
men, right? Like, you set up all these straw men. Now, you're
I'm not setting anything up. Well, then explain to me explain
to me who whose point is it that you just addressed cuz it wasn't
yours. Yours. I can only address yours. No one else is making
points. The point you just addressed about how clearly you were
happy that you Cuz you're saying that I'm not. So I'm addressing
your point. Yes. I didn't say that I wasn't happy yesterday.
No, no, no. You said I was unhappy. I'm addressing that statement.
I didn't that she's generally unhappy. Now one time doesn't mean
all the time. Yesterday you were unhappy. Why are you being so
So then So then if yesterday I'm happy and I went to the barn,
therefore we can't. Can I finish? Can I finish? Therefore, we
can conclude that going to the barn has nothing to do with me
being fatigued or irritable later on and not wanting to do activities
or being snappy. I'm glad that you think that that's a cool point.
That's not a cool point. It's just a fact. um like I wouldn't
say it's proof. It could contribute, but maybe she's happy for
some. I don't know. There's lots of other things that could be
happening, but the logic works. She's now that she's actually
being snappy, dude. She's actually she is actually making like
uh fairly good points, like better than she was. Man, I don't
know why she wouldn't argue with this guy before. Now she's just
kind of winning. Congratulations. I guess I I
People don't want to be debating each other in a relationship.
I don't blame her for not because this is AIDS. Like, who would
want to be in this? Yes, this is AIDS. This is absolutely depressing.
I mean, sure. Yes, of course. What do you want me to say? You're
feeding me a thing to say yes to. So, I say yes. No, I'm just
I'm illustrating that your statement is invalid. Then my opinion
is invalid. I suppose I suppose it's not an op it's my opinion
is that my opinion, you're right. It's a little more than opinion,
but like you have said I'm citing specifically the times when
you do say it. You keep bringing up the times when you don't
say it. I'm not disputing that. Not I'm not saying every single
time we go to the table is a show. I'm not saying that. I'm not
even saying usually. What I'm saying is that the situation surrounding
going to the stable is typically not super happy of a situation.
How? Everyone having a good Yes, cool. They just loop back to
the start of this conversation where he said this and she goes,
"Wait, why?" And he doesn't give examples. I'm having a good
time. Dad's having a good time. You don't have to do anything
there. You can choose to ride a horse. You can choose not to.
I feel like it's not unhappy. We see Autumn there. She's happy.
Like it's because you literally are unpleasant in the pre-math.
How? And the aftermath. The pre-math. What do you mean? The the
before we go. I'm I'm not unpleasant. Then the mornings you are
quite unpleasant. Do you mean when I ask you to get up and you're
not up yet and I say we have to go? That's not being unpleasant.
That's trying to get to my lesson on time. Um it's it's mainly
the way that you do it. How what do you mean? How can I How can
I express to you that time is of the urgency in a more happy
chipper way? See, that is the challenge, isn't it? Like like
that that is the ch Okay, here's here's the facts. Okay, Amar
has like one thing she so two things she cares about. They're
both animals. Her dogs and her horses, right? Her animals and
her horses. If you know that she has a booked thing at a certain
time and you are consistently not ready to go for that thing,
even though you need to help in some way, then yeah, she's going
to start getting annoyed with you. But that is your fault. You're
the person who knows, right? Like you're in a relationship. She's
got this thing she wants to do on Fridays. If she's got a lesson
or writing thing and you know she has to be there, like yeah,
you're blatantly telegraphing. You don't give a about that. If
you're just constantly later sleeping in for it, obviously challenge
like how do you express something in a way that isn't abrasive
to your partner when it's between something you want and what
you need them to do. Yeah. Yeah. I understand that it's challenging,
right? If you're saying it's challenging, yes, it is. But like,
we're not arguing whether it's challenging. We're arguing whether
if it's pleasant or not. And that it's most certainly not, right?
Like like I don't think I've ever done anything to you unpleasant.
I'm just saying, "Hey, get up. We need to go." If that was the
voice you used, it is. You're just
sleepy. I get you're sleepy, but that's not me being unpleasant.
Like, hey, Nick, get up. We got to go. We got to go. Make it
sound like that. We got to go, man. Sure. Like, it's always very
pleasant. Does Amaranth drive? I don't know if she drives, but
Nick is the cameraman currently. So, Nick would have to go with
her, right? Or else she'd need to hire a different cameraman.
I just don't like it for I mean, I'm not saying having to wake
up in the morning early is pleasant, but it's not inherently
unpleasant. Here's the point. Here's the point, right? This is
something you have to do sometimes. The point was this. If you
it's that you know like you would think that your I myself would
be preferable being Jesus correctly. I just I don't know how
there needs to be intervention or they're eventually going to
feel this way too. I don't know how they don't feel this way
already. I don't know how Amaran has avoided it. Yeah, it's very
shocking. Kind of brought into the fold with the equestrian stuff.
I'm just trying to wake you up in the morning. I'm just being
reminded how much better being single is than being in a relationship.
It is so much better.
It is so good because these types of relationships make you feel
so much worse about yourself that you forget the baseline level
that's actually quite decent. Like this is okay. This is insane.
Or or or or attractively kind of brought into the fold with the
equestrian stuff. Well, I'm just trying to wake you up in the
morning. Why are you complicating it? Okay. I'm sorry. You're
right. I'll let you statement. Yeah. It's not I'm not laughing.
I know. I'm I'm I was not actually He has de facto pimped her
out on Only Fans. Um I think that it's not healthy for your partner
to have control over as much stuff as he does considering the
uh the abuse allegations, right? I think in 2022
um stuff should have changed, right? is she should have got a
social media manager or only fans manager or both or whatever
and he should have stepped back from a lot of these things because
the fact that she doesn't have privacy in her own DMs or any
like means to I don't know how much control he has over everything
that she does contactwise is insane. I don't know if I'd call
him a pimp but I would probably call him pretty controlling.
I don't know if there's real financial abuse or it's sort of
I don't know cuz they're both sort of reluctant to do anything
about it. So I'm not sure but it's still very bad. I don't know.
It's bad. What do you want her to say? Also means asked to cry.
Like I did you see laughing like like we're both usually when
someone says that it implies that I think it's a joke. You feel
it qualifies under course of control. I don't know. I'm not sure.
It's like I don't know if she just like literally has free access
to all of her money and she could just go do whatever she likes
and contact whoever she likes and set up her own things or whether
he would literally interfere with absolutely everything. I have
no clue. It's pretty difficult from outside perspective to really
make a judgment. Wasn't sure why you said that. Thanks for explaining
like great. So, so what is it that you want? How can I make the
mornings when I try to wake you up more pleasant? So, you can't
say that the getting to the barn is unpleasant for you. you're
just overly indexing on that. Like I'm trying to tell you that
it's like a combination of that and the after. And like if you
sit there and say, "Oh, that's never happened before." Well then,
okay. Um I guess we just disagree, right? Like there's no I do
know that if I was married to him, I would be in jail. You guys
what I was trying to get. I told you what I'm trying to solve
for here. Uh people who need attention desperately. Attention
seekers, head to general chat. And if you can type, you can make
memes and I will time you up for 28 days. Attention seekers into
the general chat so you can be banned permanently.
Go ahead. Sorry. What did you say, Kelly? I said if I was married
to him, I would be in jail from a murder charge. And then you
just I don't know. I think you just ignored that completely.
Can you I'll adjust it again. What can I do differently to make
the mornings when I'm trying to wake you up more pleasant so
that we can actually get to my lesson on time if you want to
go with me still. You don't have to, but earlier in the car you
mentioned that you do want to help. So, it's it's the same way
as what I've had to learn to motivate you to do things, right?
Like the idea is um What do you mean workout three times a week
before you go see your horses? Like what? How do I make that
a dose? Because to me that's not pleasant. So what can I do?
I mean is that pleasant for you? You see you see how how nuanced
it is. That perfect example right there. No that's how you feel.
The amount of evidence that she has if she did off him. I feel
like she could just play the stream to the court and they would
be like actually we understand. You're free to go. Yeah. Yeah.
That's not pleasant. So what can I do? I mean is that pleasant
for you? You see you see how how nuanced it is? That perfect
example right there. No that's how you I don't think that's unpleasant.
No, I don't. But you clearly do. Right. No. So how what version
of that can I do then if you'd find that not unpleasant? So if
you're saying if I do something of that variety to you that is
pleasant to you. So what is that for you where it's like don't
get a bor job unless you wake up on time or something and then
it's like giving you motivation. I don't know. Sure. I mean like
you're asking me to solve for how you can be more pleasant. I
can tell you where you're unpleasant but for me to solve for
where you could be pleasant implies that you know I have some
ability to actually get you to do something which Okay. No. No.
I think that's great. So, if you wake up in the morning, all
right, and we get to my lesson on time, I will give you a [__]
that evening. And if we don't,
Dude, why does she do that? Why is everything about [__]
I'm losing my mind. I I think that's She's literally She literally
thinks that's all he wants from her. That's like ultimately like
one of the only things he cares about. That's ultimately like
No, I get it's sad, but it's But she doesn't explain this to
the audience. So all we get is like the most deranged responses
about [__] She has provided text. You can see it.
I feel like you should because if you're going to keep mentioning
[__] this often, it does look really weird. And it's
like girl, you don't have to say it. And like nobody nobody who's
watching this doesn't have the context here. I don't know. Uh
it makes the clips better to be honest with you. Wake up on time
and we're late. Then I won't give that evening. But then also
here's the situation. You can't blame the fact that I went to
the barn on the reason why I'm not giving you a [__]
It's because you didn't get up on time. Is that unfair? Yes,
with a caveat. Admittedly, he's not telling her to stop talking
about [__]
That counts whether you're ready or get there or not. Wait, did
he just did he just totally accept this framework? You can't
blame the fact that I went to the barn on the reason why I'm
not giving you a [__] It's because you didn't get
up on time. Is that unfair? Yes. With a caveat. He just accepts
it. He just accepts it. He's just like, "Yeah, we're going to
negotiate for blowjobs." Yep. Yep. Yep. You set a time for me
to be ready to go. Okay. If I'm ready by then, then it counts
whether you're ready to actually get there or not. Sure. I feel
like that's fair. Yeah. And that's fine. But like you see, like
that's already better, but like I'm telling it like every other
time. It's literally you just browbeating me to get up, which
is fine. I get it. Brow beating you. What does that mean? I'm
just like, "Hey, get up." Cuz you're not getting up. So, I mean,
yeah, that's like how my mom used to have to be like, "Hey, get
up for school." And if you don't do it, she has to come in and
say it again. I really hope your mom didn't do anything like
what you just suggested, Amaranth, for the love of God. How else
am I supposed to do that if you're not waking up? It's the exact
same as how you expect me to wake you up in a non-abbrasive way.
It's the same thing. Like, how do I do it? I get up close to
you. I, you know, roll over and I generally like embrace you.
And then I said, "Hey, Kaitlin." Like, like it's it's a lot nicer
than like just literally, you know, drill sergeant getting you
out of bed. When? When? What? Like, be more specific. What are
you asking? Uh, she's she's saying this doesn't happen. I totally
believe this happens. If like she's excited for the thing and
Nick doesn't care, then yeah, that's going to annoy you and you're
going to be like, "Get the up. We got to get there. Get the up
right now. I I totally get it. Maybe like on the rare just do
more things on their own. But do you mean historically or time?
What are you talking about? Well, I think right now she doesn't
have a cameraman. She doesn't have somebody helping her. She
doesn't have like an assistant for those things. So Nick has
said he wants to step in in that capacity. So he has to be ready
to step up. She does need an assistant, right? She needs somebody
who's holding the camera watching her ride around on her horse.
Hire someone again cuz this is obviously not what Yeah, that's
Hold on. That's exactly what I said though is she needs to But
Nick said, "No, don't hire somebody. I'm going to do it." And
now she's like getting annoyed that he's not going to do it.
[__] you, Nick. I'm hiring someone. [__]
off. Sure. I don't wake you in an abrasive way. I remember you
getting upset that like my alarm goes off and I'm not up and
if I oversleep, I remember you several times getting upset. So,
I'm just trying to figure out what you mean. No, no, no. What
I'm talking Okay, first of all, that's a miscarriage of the truth,
but sure. Um, the only time they get upset are when like literally
you consciously register your alarm's ringing and then you consciously
decide you're gonna sleep through it. Now, now here's the thing.
I mean, like you I feel like in that situation, you either decide
to get up or you decide to turn it off. Don't let it just keep
ringing there because there's other people right next to you,
i.e. me also trying to sleep. And that doesn't work for any of
the rest of Well, if I'm if I'm asleep, then it's not a conscious
decision. Great. Ah, that's hold on. How many people have had
a partner like this who needs to set like eight alarms to get
up in the morning? I'm sorry. If you need to set eight alarms
to get up in the morning and then you start dating somebody,
uh, you need to fix your [__] You need to actually
man up and fix it or woman up and fix your Okay. You cannot You
got to sleep next to somebody and hit snooze eight times as up.
Is she the snoozer or is he the snoozer? You know, it sounds
like she's the snoozer. Like she's she's not getting up when
the alarm's going off and then he gets annoyed. And I mean, yeah,
you just you got to be able to get up. Okay, then say you work.
But sure, they should sleep in separate rooms and maybe they
would sleep better and maybe that would fix like half of these
problems. Register it and then you decide that you're just going
to sleep through it. That happens. You realize people press snooze
when they're still like Yeah, you didn't press anything. I know.
That's my problem. Like like you just let it Well, then if I
if I didn't get up and I didn't press anything, then I didn't
register it. You got up, you looked at it, you checked your phone,
and you went back to sleep. I don't know what the [__]
I don't remember that. So then it wasn't conscious. Just like
sometimes you speak Mandarin to me. I don't think that that's
conscious. Sure. But it certainly looks conscious. I mean, things
can look conscious, but I mean, whatever you want to define it
as, right? Like, however you want to. Well, then we have a solution
though. Okay. So, if I give you level of petty we've gotten to
the night before, Jesus Christ. Okay. And I say if we if we can
make this time, then I will give you that. I mean, it's time
better than it was. At least there's something you know. What
the is this? It's like a reward system [__] if we
get on time. This is so bizarre. Yes, it is very odd. But honestly,
like like my point was overarching. You should be practicing
on winning me over. I hate it to horses because how how have
I not like Okay, convince me not to hate the horses. Okay. You've
interacted with them. How has there been bad experiences? Cuz
I can't recall any. It's mainly just that at these things, right?
Like unless it's like fall or winter, it's generally incredibly
like discomforting to be there. Oh, it's just the heat of Texas.
Yeah, that's a part of it. Correct. Okay. I can't control the
Why is this an argument now? The whole thing was that she was
a [__] Why are you making other arguments about how
it sucks? It's like she basically just took his only argument
away that you're we don't have or something. She took his only
argument away and now he's like switched on to something entirely
different. If we had her own ranch, you could be air conditioned.
You can control when and how often you go. I mean, I I go as
early as I can. They get there at 8 a.m., you know, and then
like classes don't start till 9:00 and I have the first lesson,
you know? I don't know why I even try. Like I'm trying to get
to something and then I get Well, you're trying to act like it's
within my control to make that a better experience for you, but
I literally can't control the weather. Literally, you derailed
my point. So, I don't know why the you think What? What? What
did I derail? What I was talking about? Yeah, but you you just
said that being there is unpleasant because it's hot because
you wouldn't let me say any other thing when I was trying to
keep going. I was like, I didn't realize you were going. Okay.
I literally said, are you just going to Okay, sure. Like, I'm
sorry. I didn't realize I did that. Keep going. What else can
I help with? Do you want to cycle it back like 30 seconds and
then just see? Cuz I was like, okay, why does he Hold on. Why
does he need her? She just was like, "Oh, I didn't realize I
was doing that. Go ahead." And then he's like, "Do I have to
back it up to prove that you just did this to me?" No, she said,
"Go ahead. Go finish your list." We can't do it on the phone.
You have to get a computer and I'm eating right now. But just
I'm sorry if I cut you off. I did not know. I thought you that
was the end of your point. But please finish. But besides weather
makes it unpleasant that I could help with. I'm Anyways, I'm
just going to say the point I was saying before you try to graph
that on. My point was, you should be seeing as an opportunity
that you have a chance to win someone over to horses and you
can try a few different ways of doing it because ultimately if
you want to do this as content, well, there's already people
who do horse content. That's already a thing. But that's not
content is not you being won over. So, how can I win you over
without content? Like, just disregard content because for the
rest of our life, we're mostly not going to be streaming. Okay,
you're you're missing the point. I didn't say like what do you
I love how you think it all makes so much sense and I have no
idea what the you're latching on to. No. No. through John, evil
Johnny Bravo. As she pulls, as she gains more strength to fight
back in the relationship, to have actual arguments with him,
she is slowly learning and gaining the human cognitive ability
of chewing her food. Okay. She is chewing the out of this pasta
right now, getting obliterated. I'm just saying don't bring content
cuz I'm asking for even we go to the bar and sometimes not on
stream. Why are you saying that? I mean, I feel like if you were
arguing and eating pasta at the same time and you didn't chew,
you'd probably just choke. Uh, well, she didn't chew before and
she swallowed it just fine. So, yeah, but she wasn't having a
debate with a at the time. What I'm saying is that it's a chance
for you to evangelize about your passion for horses. Take that
thought just I'm not trying to evangelize. I'm asking what can
I do to make the experience better for you, you enjoying the
horses themselves. Don't bring content at all. Say we're not
streaming and this is a day where it's still hot. Okay, what
else can I do? You're not going to hear anything if you just
keep trying to force your very, very rigid message down. Everyone's
still It's not a rigid message. I'm asking like cuz you keep
bringing content back into the conversation saying you win. Oh,
hello. What is this? Barry Q with another Didn't you I thought
you did one of these already today, but thank you. I'm very confused.
I thought you did this already. Uh she swallowed pasta. It was
the most up thing I've ever seen in my Okay, disregard. Can you
uh can you disregard that and actually hear the context in which
I am bringing it in? Because I'm not saying that oh because of
content it's unpleasant. I'm not saying I'm not saying that either.
I'm Well, great. But but then what I'm saying is that do you
realize that it's two and the same? If you can win someone over
and explain to them and and show them why you're so passionate
about horses, right? Like then what? What? I thought this whole
thing was about how she was like rude to him when she'd gone
to the horses. He's just trying to hate the horses in any way
and now it's hey, why don't you convince me that the horses are
cool? Okay, convince me that the horses are cool. That's a skill
set of being able to win someone over. That's going to be useful
in terms of you evangelizing or or converting more people. I
don't I'm don't see you're bringing in the con converting and
evangelizing and I'm not I'm just trying to spend time with my
husband with my animals like I'm trying to spend time with all
the people and creatures I love. I feel like you have some cognitive
dissonance. So if you are not trying to in any way evangelize
or or or or teach people about this stuff then what is the point
of stream because we have a kick contract and we're trying to
stream everything in our life. Yes. Thank you for very saying
very obvious.